Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Britlaf und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe 94 und auch heute soll's wieder über die Ukraine gehen und äh deswegen spreche ich auch heute wieder mit Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Genau, wir haben uns nämlich vorgenommen jetzt hm in dieser Phase mal alle paar Tage so zusammenzukommen, vielleicht nicht so jede Woche, weil wir immer Angst haben, dass ich dann auf einmal zu viel ereignet hat.
Man dann nicht mehr so richtig den Überblick bekommt.
Jetzt muss ich sagen, seit dem letzten Mal ist das nicht unbedingt passiert, aber vielleicht ist das auch ganz gut so, dass man sich auch nochmal auf ein paar Sachen konzentrieren kann.
Heute mal machen. Sprich wir wollen mal versuchen erstmal so einen ja einen aktuellen Stand der Dinge zusammenzufassen, so wie er sich uns darstellt, ja.
Und dann wollen wir nochmal über so ein paar Meter Themen reden, nämlich so ein bisschen die internationale Situation, insbesondere im Bezug auf China und ähm auch nochmal,
Blick selber auf Putin und das System Putin werfen. So, mit dem.
Du dich ja vor allem viel beschäftigt hast in den letzten Tagen. Ja das ist so ein bisschen ähm.
Sinn der ganzen Sache. Kommen wir da erstmal so zum zur Ist-Situation.
Also aus meiner Perspektive.
Kann man sagen, hat sich jetzt in den letzten vier, fünf Tagen ähm.
Insgesamt wenig geändert. Das bedeutet, dass.
Die Ukrainer jetzt rein militärisch im Wesentlichen so den Widerstand aufrecht erhalten können.
Nicht heißt, dass die Russen keine Fortschritte erzielt hätten. Allerdings sind diese Fortschritte überschaubar.
Und ich denke man muss so im Wesentlichen drei.
Mmh vielleicht vier verschiedene Bereiche in der Ukraine.
Unterscheiden, zumal ja das Kriegsgeschehen da auch noch relativ getrennt voneinander läuft.
Ähm da gibt's einerseits natürlich die Situation um Kiew, die so auch in der ganzen Berichterstattung immer so im Vordergrund steht. Dann gibt's natürlich den ganzen ähm.
Einbruch im Osten des Landes, also dem Donbass.
Das Ganze äh Donetsk Becken und natürlich der Vorstoß von der Krim aus, von Süden aus.
Und ähm dann gibt's halt noch den restlichen Bereich der Ukraine, also vor allem halt die gesamte Westukraine
die halt nur eigentlich unten von der Krim aus bisher angegriffen wird und natürlich mit Flugangriffen, die gefahren werden.
Es gab jetzt verschiedene Bombardierungen von Flughäfen in der Westukraine.
Ist natürlich ein Ziel und heute gab's, glaube ich, sogar in der Nähe der polnischen Grenze einen Angriff auf so einen Truppenstandort. Also solche Spitzen werden da immer wieder geflogen, aber das ist natürlich nicht so massiv.
Und das die Hauptaufmerksamkeit gilt natürlich dem Vorstoß im Süden.
Also mein Eindruck ist auch und da gibt's allerdings nicht allzu viele Daten
Punkte äh für im Wesentlichen ähm so ist ein Datenpunkt dieser äh Equipment Lost Tracker, den wir auch schon mal vor einigen Sendungen äh erwähnt hatten auf
Urxes Pianoskop oder so äh und.
Ähm gut das ist jetzt zwar nur auch eine Stichprobe und die ist natürlich auch beeinflusst durch ja Informationslage aber.
Ich habe das halt verfolgt und die Zerstörungen dort oder die zerstörten oder eroberten Geräte waren,
am Anfang so am am ersten dritten ungefähr ähm drei zu eins, also die Russen sagen dreimal mehr verloren äh als die,
Ukrainer und dieses Verhältnis ist über die Zeit dort auf der Seite ungefähr stabil
geblieben. So es sind äh allerdings, was man sieht, ist, dass wenn man diese Zahlen jetzt einfach mal als halbwegs repräsentative Stichproben nimmt, dann äh könnte man da zwei Dinge draus ableiten
Erstens, dass die Intensität der Kämpfe deutlich
abgenommen hat. Äh das ist halt langsamer äh geworden ist. Also die Zahlen steigen langsamer an auf beiden Seiten an zerstörten oder eroberten Equipment und das Verhältnis.
Ungefähr gleich geblieben. Das heißt, ähm ja,
Kämpfe werden weniger intensiv, aber es ist nicht zu sehen, dass eine Seite jetzt irgendwo Oberhand gewinnen äh würde, sondern dass das Kräfteverhältnis sagen ungefähr gleich ist und wenn, dann geht
beiden äh ungefähr gleich so die Puste aus also das das ist was,
Ich glaube, äh was was man ähm im Moment daraus daraus ableiten
äh kann. Ähm des Weiteren ja äh haben die Russen natürlich auch jetzt damit zu tun, je größer dass.
Eroberte Gebiet ist, umso mehr müssen sie natürlich ihre Truppen dort verteilen, um das auch zu sichern. Das heißt, je größer das Gebiet ist, umso weniger Truppen äh an der Front äh stehen für Feindkontakt.
Zur Verfügung, also war das auch ungefähr zu erwarten, dass jetzt gerade je länger es dauert äh im im Schnitt.
So weniger intensiv äh die die Kämpfe werden. Das ist jetzt nichts Überraschendes. Auf der anderen Seite
ja sind ja kaum,
Städte, größere Städte erobert äh worden, Mario Pohl äh ist
immer noch hm ja nicht nicht erobert äh so, was was halt auch verrückt
ist, weil das ja komplett so auf auf allen Seiten und von von sie aus ja komplett von von Russen äh um umzingelt ist und auch nicht nicht so weit
weg von von irgendwas, aber ja so einfach scheint es dann nicht nicht zu sein äh.
Darf voran äh zu rücken und auf der anderen Seite hm,
ja müssen die Russen jetzt nicht unbedingt auch große Eile walten lassen, wobei wir haben in der letzten Sendung auch schon gesagt hatten, dass möglicherweise.
Uhr doch
etwas zum Vorteil der Ukraine tickt, zumindest was die Zahl der Soldaten angeht, weil sie ja theoretisch hm ja wahrscheinlich ungefähr zehn Millionen Mann oder Mann, Männer und Frauen zur Verfügung haben.
Die sie irgendwie einsetzen können, nur die sind natürlich alle nicht nicht notwendigerweise bewaffnet oder äh oder aktiviert, aber
Das äh werden natürlich mehr und mehr Truppen bewaffnet und aktiviert und ähm zusammengestellt.
Natürlich relativ wenig Überblick
jetzt über den den Ressourcenverbrauch und und die die Lage, also was wie viel Munitionsreserven und wie viel Waffen und und schweres Gerät da sind und wie viel da jetzt
nachkommt äh in der in der Ukraine. Das das kann man halt schwer sagen. Ähm aber.
Grundsätzlich wie gesagt ist ist was was so die Soldaten äh angeht äh ist die Ukraine einfach im im Vorteil, wenn es gelingt,
äh dort eben genug Material und Ausrüstung und und Waffen äh für die bereitzustellen.
Das ist so die grundsätzliche Frage, inwiefern der ukrainischen Armee es jetzt hier äh gelingt wirklich da ähm diese Versorgungslinie immer wieder zu schließen. Prinzip sind die.
Russischen Truppen ziemlich angreifbar, hatten das hier ja auch schon mehrfach erwähnt, also allein, wenn man sich auf.
Tankwagen zum Beispiel konzentriert, ja? Kann man schon eine ganze Menge äh verhindern, weil dann einfach Panzer nicht vorankommen. Wobei man jetzt sagen muss, die.
Positionen sind jetzt halt weitgehend gefunden. Dieser lange Stau hat sich ein bisschen aufgelöst, die ganzen ähm einzelnen Fahrzeuge haben sich so ein bisschen in die Büsche verteilt, um nicht mehr so leicht angreifbar zu sein.
Das ist schon so eine Reaktion und es ist vor allem sehr viel Artillerie und eben auch diese,
furchtbaren Longreden, Schrankenwerfer, die halt was weiß ich glaube ich bis zu 100 Kilometern überbrücken können. Die sind halt alle positioniert und die müssen im Prinzip jetzt ähm angegriffen werden, um halt diesen Raketenbeschuss in irgendeiner Form in den Griff zu bekommen.
Trotzdem diese Versorgung. Ich meine, da sind ja auch Soldaten, die wollen irgendwie was essen, die wollen ne, die müssen.
Deiner Form versorgt werden. Wenn das halt zusammenbricht, dann wird's schwierig und so die Situation an sich ist äh da eh nicht äh schön für russische Soldaten, aber das ist halt nun mal so in der russischen Armee. Ich glaube die sind nichts besseres gewöhnt.
Wie katastrophal das jetzt im Einzelnen ist,
weiß ich nicht, aber na ja, noch läuft es auf jeden Fall weiter. Die Situation da um Mariopol, ja das ist insofern erstaunlich, wie du schon sagst, ähm das ist halt äh keine besonders große Stadt,
Trotzdem der Widerstand ist halt da und ähm.
So so gelingt es eben auch der ukrainischen Armee. Die Russen die ganze Zeit beschäftigt zu halten und mit jedem Kilometer, den sie sich halt irgendwo weiter ins Land tasten
stretcht sich äh diese ganze Versorgungskette entsprechend und wird dann auch angreifbar. Im Süden konnten sie allerdings diese ganzen Fortschritte auch machen, weil,
Ukraine sie in gewisser Hinsicht auch gelassen hat, denn sie wollen ja auch verhindern, dass Truppenteile jetzt komplett abgeschnitten werden durch irgendwelche Vorstöße. Also das ist ja dann so eingekesselt und,
eigenen Versorgung abgeschnitten werden und es ist halt auch so, dass eben.
Es für sie schon drum geht auch die strategischen Orte zu halten, also dass sie in den großen Städten wie und äh Sumi da im im Osten.
Dass die Russen dort nicht wirklich vorankommen und nicht in der Lage sind, diese Städte einzunehmen, dass äh hindert die Russen schon extrem, weil das eben auch wichtig für die ganzen Transportwege ist et cetera.
Und genauso ist es halt im.
Süden, da stehen sie halt jetzt, also ist ja jetzt gerade in den letzten Tagen viel über äh Jazzhorn berichtet worden, wo sie jetzt irgendwie anfangen, schon irgendwelche Wahlen abzuhalten und so weiter, wollen ja alle jetzt irgendwie auch Russland beitreten, na klar.
Und dann äh gibt es diesen Vorstoß, also es gibt da so einen wenn man mal auf die ukrainische Landkarte äh schaut,
Hat ja da links unten in der Ukraine am Schwarzen Meer gibt's ja Odessa. Ist natürlich äh noch mal ein wichtiges Ziel für die Russen. Wichtiger Hafen.
Derzeit eben noch nicht wirklich angegriffen
Sobald ich das die äh ist der Ukraine es gelungen halt einfach die Gefahr von Seeseite durch Seemin erstmal äh in Schach zu halten und über Land. Müssten sie dann eben erstmal mehrere dieser Wasser
Gebiete überschreiten und,
zwei Stellen, wo die Russen überhaupt über eine Brücke kommen könnten. Die werden halt auch äh sind auch entsprechend heftig umkämpft. In äh.
Oh Gott äh und ähm weiter nördlich heißt das. Hätte ich mal Russisch genommen in der Schule.
Gar nicht. Ich kann's nicht anders wiedergeben, als es jetzt hier bei Google Earth mir dargestellt wird, weil auf Kerödisch kann ich's nicht lesen.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall da äh da hakt es an dieser Stelle.
Ja und in Kiew ist die Situation eigentlich nach wie vor dieselbe, dass halt die Attacken von Nordosten und von Nordwesten kommen und äh da wird halt um jeden Meter.
Gekämpft. Insgesamt
gab's wohl Fortschritte und die Bedrohung besteht jetzt im Wesentlichen halt in diesen äh Raketenwerfern noch, allerdings gibt es halt Zugang vom Rest des Landes. Das heißt, Kiew ist immer noch in der äh Versorgung vom Westen.
Das Gleiche gilt natürlich auch für die anderen Städte außer Mariopol und äh insofern können halt auch nach wie vor Waffen geliefert werden, Nahrungsmittel geliefert werden et cetera und natürlich auch Flüchtende.
Ausgefahren werden.
Ähm zu Odessa äh vielleicht noch in dem Zusammenhang äh habe ich gehört, dass äh äh dort
auch dieses dieses eine Schiff äh was äh angeblich die
Soldaten da auf der Insel, die die dann irgendwie mit äh Fuck You Russian Waship äh geantwortet äh haben, dass das wohl versenkt wurde.
So dass äh mhm das russische Schiff, das äh die die Insel äh äh da äh erobert hat oder die dreizehn.
Daship.
Ja, das Russian Warship, genau. Also insgesamt sind wohl sind wohl jetzt zwei äh äh russische Kriegsschiffe versenkt äh worden, äh hörte ich und eins davon äh war eben das Russian Warship äh.
Haben wir die Story überhaupt so erzählt? Nee, ich glaube gar nicht mal, ne? Also vielleicht kennt ihr ja auch nicht jeder.
Also es gibt da so eine kleine Insel im Schwarzen Meer. Äh wie heißt die nochmal offiziell?
Schlangeninsel ist das. Die Schlangeninsel,
Insular äh sehr pilor. Das ist eine wirklich eine sehr, sehr, sehr kleine äh Insel mit einem Schwarzen Meer. Die ist jetzt auch strategisch ähm.
Jetzt erstmal für den Krieg so nicht äh entscheidend, weil die auch ziemlich weit draußen ist.
Da ist er halt sind die Russen irgendwie aufgetaucht und haben halt gesagt so ja hier äh.
Gebt euch, wir sind hier russisches äh Kriegsschiff irgendwie äh gibt mir gibt mir die Insel und da waren irgendwie so 16 Leute stationiert. Und das lief so über Funk.
Und die, da gibt's so eine Originalaufzeichnung, wo man sich das anhören kann, dass die sich auch noch kurz irgendwie abgestimmt haben, also da soll ich ihm sagen, also sollen sich
To go fuck them safe und
ja okay und dann ja Russian go fuck you so das war dann so ihre Antwort, ne? Natürlich Instant Heroes äh geworden. Es gab dann
erstmal die Meldung, dass die dann alle im Rahmen eines Angriffs dort getötet wurden. Später wurde das widerrufen und angeblich sind alle am Leben. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da jetzt wirklich passiert ist.
Aber das ist eben diese Schlangeninsel.
Und äh ja und aber russian äh soll jetzt versenkt äh worden.
Okay, gut.
Ja ähm.
Ja äh zur ich meine habe ich noch zu militärischen Gesamtsituationen oder wie sich das wie sich das jetzt entwickeln äh kann. Also einmal ist.
Schon natürlich klar, es geht definitiv langsamer als die Russen des,
erwartet haben. Da sind sich praktisch alle Fachleute jetzt einig, einschließlich des äh Putin auch unzufrieden ist und ja generelle gefeuert hat und so. Das wird da nicht tun, wenn alles äh super läuft. Ähm
aber ähm man Russland muss natürlich jetzt die Situation auch neu bewerten. Das heißt.
Hm äh ja, sie passen sich natürlich auch an äh jetzt an die veränderte taktische Situation und haben jetzt sicherlich einen neuen Plan oder oder Zeitplan.
Gemacht, äh wo sie jetzt, wo sie jetzt hinwollen oder überhaupt hin können und
Denke mal, äh die sind jetzt auch alle keine keine Vollidioten, das heißt
Die haben jetzt natürlich auch gewisse Metriken äh sage ich mal wissen, wie schnell sie jetzt vorankommen. Das heißt, sie haben jetzt auch äh können jetzt ihre Erwartungen ähm besser
anpassen so. Also wir können jetzt sagen wir mal besser planen. Eigentlich als das vor dem Angriff eigentlich möglich war.
Das heißt, ähm ja.
Da durch kommt natürlich jetzt eine gewisse Unsicherheit äh rein, dass die Russen jetzt ihre Pläne und ihre Vorgehensweise wahrscheinlich ändern und anpassen. Mhm.
Auf der anderen Seite hm ich weiß nicht wie gut jetzt die Eisenbahnverbindungen eigentlich unterbrochen sind. Ähm.
Und wie lange das dauert dann äh diese wieder in Stand zu setzen, aber,
das kann jetzt auch nicht Jahre oder Jahrzehnte dauern. Äh kann ich mir jetzt nicht nicht vorstellen, äh sondern äh da besteht natürlich die Gefahr, dass äh wenn jetzt.
Die Russen Teile des ukrainischen Eisenbahnnetzes angeschlossen
äh bekommen, dann äh könnten sie natürlich auch in größerem Ausmaß äh viel leichter Material heranschaffen und sich sich versorgen. Ähm
insofern ja äh etwas fluide äh Situation, äh dass das Ganze und ähm.
Sie stehen halt jetzt vor der Welt, sagen wir mal äh zumindest ja schon jetzt mit der Blamage äh da. Das heißt, sie können sich jetzt.
Erstmal vielleicht ein bisschen mehr mehr Zeit lassen, also für äh und weiter sich vorsichtig äh voran tasten und äh sind sicherlich auch jetzt vorsichtiger geworden.
So wie's wie's aussieht und ja.
Dass das wie gesagt zur zur nochmal zur Situation äh wie ich das wie ich das einschätze, was da sich jetzt passieren kann, was sich da verändern kann und.
Sie müssen natürlich schon.
Gucken wenn sie jetzt dann weitere neue Offensiven starten sollen, müssen sie natürlich ja dann auch erstmal Kräfte äh versammeln oder neue Kräfte aufbauen
denen sie dann äh vielleicht hier und da einen größeren Push äh vornehmen können.
Es ist auch schon erstaunlich, ich habe jetzt leider nicht die genauen Zahlen da, aber ähm.
Es ist schon so, dass von dem tatsächlich einsetzbaren Truppen. Die Russland so zur Verfügung steht.
Ein Großteil im Kampf gegen die Ukrainer schon aufgefahren worden ist. Also.
Habe so was gehört wie äh es gibt so 168 Einheiten äh in.
Bataillons.
Bataillone der gesamten Armee.
Und davon sind irgendwie so hundert1zwanzig oder so hier im Einsatz. Und ist jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt die anderen auch noch alle holen können.
Weil.
Ist ja ein großes Land, so. Die stehen halt dann woanders und beschützen da quasi ihr Land. Weil im Zweuerfall müssen sie ja auch damit rechnen irgendwo nochmal Ärger zu bekommen.
Das bedeutet, dass diese Verstärkung, dieser Truppen gar nicht so ohne Weiteres möglich ist. Es ist dieses ähm her ist halt nicht.
Beliebig groß. Natürlich könnten sie jetzt eine Mobilmachung des gesamten Landes einleiten.
Ja und hätten natürlich alle Reservisten dann theoretisch auch noch am am Start, also sie könnten so wie die ganze Ukraine jetzt mobil gemacht hat und äh kein äh kein Mann bis, ich weiß nicht, zu welchem Alter.
16, 16 bis 60, glaube ich oder also achtzehn.
Das Land nicht verlassen darf, weil im Prinzip brauchen sie halt jede Hilfe. Das Problem ist, dass halt Russland das nicht so ohne weiteres machen kann.
Weil das wäre ja dann auch ein bisschen das Eingeständnis, dass jetzt hier so ein Largescale äh Krieg oder ein richtiger Verteidigungsfall vorliegt,
bisher ist das Ganze ja nur so eine Spezialoperation in ihrer eigenen Propagandasprache und was braucht man für eine Spezialoperation schon, spezielles Personal?
Ja, also es wäre natürlich höchst unpopulär in in Russland plus äh dass die Leute dann natürlich am Arbeitsplatz fehlen. Das muss man muss man dann auch auch sehen, dass das natürlich die Wirtschaft.
Auch beeinträchtigt, wenn du jetzt da auch noch mal hunderttausende von von Leuten irgendwo äh abziehst
und äh ja,
Aber ähm da geht noch, da geht durchaus wahrscheinlich schon noch was bei den Russen, aber eben es ist halt halt so ein so ein so ein Kalkül natürlich wie viel Probleme handelt man sich dann zu Hause,
wenn man da jetzt zu viele Leute an die an die Front schickt
aber sie könnten natürlich was sie natürlich machen können es sind ja nicht nur auch alles alles unbedingt Kampftruppen die man da braucht sondern dann zur Befriedung und das Besetzen des Landes
natürlich auch Polizei äh Truppen und und andere ja ich sage mal Paramilitärs noch noch mit dazu äh schicken.
Plus natürlich auch äh weiß nicht, alle möglichen ja Ingenieure oder Bauarbeiter, die dann äh auch Brücken in
setzen und äh und solche Dinge, das darf man jetzt auch nicht auch nicht vergessen. Ähm das sind nicht nur alles alles Kampftruppen, die du da, die du da brauchst.
Klar, aber das ist natürlich dann leichte Beute für die ukrainische Armee, ne, die sich natürlich eingräbt in ihrem äh Land. Das Ganze würde nur dann funktionieren, wenn sie totale Kontrolle habe und die totale Kontrolle über die ganze Ukraine mit 150.000 Leuten ist halt überhaupt nicht möglich.
Nee, nee, das ist äh völlig illusorisch.
Und und wenn halt jetzt auch schon äh ich meine,
wieder schwierig mit den Zahlen so den Schätzungen, aber auch die Amerikaner haben ja, glaube ich, ihre Schätzungen ein bisschen nach oben korrigiert auf zuletzt äh6tausend Tote, russische Soldaten und die Ukraine war ja eh schon über zehntausend.
So oder so ähm kann man davon ausgehen, dass all das Gerät und all das Personal, was sie dort äh bisher angekarrt haben.
Könnte schon so zu zehn Prozent dezimiert worden sein.
Gerät und äh Waffen und Raketen und so weiter betrifft, davon haben die Russen eine ganze Menge. Ja, aber die müssen da halt auch erstmal hin. Und.
Bilder der Verstärkung über ihre Bahnlinien
womit man ja diese ganze Aufrüstung im Vorfeld schon hat ganz gut beobachten können, weil die fahren ja alles mit Zügen hin und her und da steht dann halt einfach da so drauf, ne. Kam halt am Anfang so die Panzer und die ganzen Militärwagen äh,
da jetzt mittlerweile so normale Lieferwagen und.
Fahrzeuge unterwegs. Also da da herrscht auch schon so ein bisschen Not. Also ist nicht so ganz klar inwiefern die russische Armee hier wirklich beliebig Verstärkung ranschieben kann.
Würde eher sogar sagen, also es sah Sah dann teilweise schon so aus, als wenn sie da zivile Oldtimer
als wenn sie da irgendwelche Schrottplätze äh äh wirklich äh das zusammengekratzt haben aus aus irgendwelchen Ecken. Das sah schon nicht sehr äh militärisch aus. Ähm
auch was sie da jetzt dann dann einsetzen an an Fahrzeugen, ja aber das sind halt natürlich auch immer so so.
Punktuelle äh Einblicke und so ganz hundertprozentig sicher kann man sich da nicht sein, aber.
Alle Experten sind sich einig, dass äh ja, dass es nicht dass es nicht gerade so komfortabel ist gerade die Situation.
Auch eine Menge gelesen so über.
Wie eigentlich die Stärke der russischen Armee an sich jetzt derzeit wirklich einzuschätzen ist und das auch so im.
Im Kontext der ähm bisherigen Militärgeschichte und da fand ich eine interessante Feststellung, dass die Russen eigentlich seit dem zweiten Weltkrieg.
Mit ihrer Riesenarmee eigentlich noch seitdem nie wieder so richtig gegen ein größeres Heer vorgegangen sind.
Es waren alles nur kleinere Einsätze. Also in Georgien oder äh also das Größte war wahrscheinlich Afghanistan, äh was sie seitdem.
Auch in Afghanistan statt ihnen ja sozusagen keine ausgebildete Militärmaschine gegenüber, sondern das war ja dann eben auch so ein Partisanenkampf, in dem sie ja dann auch letzten Endes täglich äh verloren haben.
Weil sie einfach dieser dieser permanenten Zersetzung äh nicht standhalten konnten mit ihrem System
und insofern ist halt jetzt der Kampf gegen die Ukraine eigentlich der zweite große Krieg nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg und jetzt haben sie es eben mit einer Armee zu tun
in gewisser Hinsicht stärker ist, als das vielleicht alle vermutet haben.
Über Motivation et cetera haben wir ja hier schon viel gesprochen. Aber was halt jetzt auch noch mit dazukommt ist.
Dass die Versorgung mit Waffenmaterial substantiell ist. Ja Ukraine hat einfach große
breite, lange Grenzen mit der EU. Es ist überhaupt gar kein Problem Zeug ins Land zu bekommen und man kann derzeit eigentlich nur davon ausgehen, dass
derzeit aus den USA und anderen Ländern.
Alles geliefert wird, was nur irgendwie geht. Also es ist sozusagen ne solange klar ist, dass man da nicht selber eingreifen kann und will und sollte.
Ist es natürlich logisch, dass man über diesen Kanal alles tut und gerade die Versorgung mit diesem Pads, also mit Stinger, Jevelyn.
Wie sie alle heißen, also diesen Schulter getragenen Panzerabwehr äh Kräften, Panzerfaust et cetera das hat sich als extrem wirksam.
Herausgestellt.
Schwedischen eight.
Ja und jetzt jetzt steht die russische Armee vor dem Problem. Das ist halt auch mit einer Armee zu tun hat, die.
Die ist jetzt auch nicht wie soll ich sagen, mitm linken Bein aufgestanden, sondern die hat jetzt seit acht Jahren Kriegsrealität.
Im Dornez gehabt.
Ist sozusagen eine permanente äh Ausbildung. Das ganze Land ist mobilisiert, das ganze Land ist geschult und ähm die kennen ihre Techniken, die kennen ihr eigenes Land und sie sind in gewisser Hinsicht auf diese ganzen Bedrohungen
auch vorbereitet gewesen. Die haben jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit äh sich gedacht so ach wird schon nichts passieren, da müssen wir jetzt nichts machen, sondern diese Pläne waren halt schon da.
Und äh konnten jetzt eben auch zum Einsatz gebracht werden und da ist sicherlich jetzt auch noch nicht.
Der der letzte Reim gesungen, sondern die die werden noch auf sehr viele Moves der Russen auch eine eine gute Antwort haben und solange sie eben diese Versorgung mit Waffen haben.
Und wahrscheinlich auch mit Intelligence, also kann nur davon ausgehen, dass sie von den Amerikanern.
Und überhaupt der ganzen NATO einfach mit Informationen.
Äh versorgt werden permanent. Ja also ich meine die Amerikaner haben's schon beeindruckt dadurch wie gut sie den ganzen äh im Vorfeld den den Angriffszeitpunkt überhaupt
vorhergesagt haben und die haben ihre äh Informanten.
Und auch an der Stelle ist natürlich so der innere Widerstand innerhalb Russlands sicherlich auch nicht zu unterschätzen. Da wird's sicherlich eine Menge Quellen geben.
Sicherlich eine Menge Leute, die einfach bereitwillig sagen, so ja hier ist eine Information für euch.
Ja, ja. Mein, mhm es gab ja auch schon
Berichte darüber, dass auch äh ja russische Truppen ihr eigenes Equipment sabotiert haben, um nicht äh voranzukommen, also Löcher in die Tanks äh gepackt haben, um dann nicht nicht weiter äh zu müssen. Es hängt auch so ein bisschen immer von von,
Bewölkung äh auch noch ab und der der
der Wetterlagen, wie gut dann äh die Satelliten äh da jetzt reingucken können. Das ist natürlich auch noch so ein Punkt,
ne? Da gab's dann so ein paar Tage, wo irgendwie dicht bewölkt war. Da war's war's dann äh nicht nicht so gut äh mit den mit den Satelliten.
Ob das Wetter ist. War jetzt äh relativ kalt. Es hat geschneit. Ein Kiew und es war so unter ähm.
Grad. Das ist natürlich insofern jetzt äh für die Russen ganz gut, weil das alles nicht ganz so schlammig ist, aber das wird sich jetzt so in den nächsten Tagen, glaube ich, dann auch nochmal wieder ändern.
Ähm ein anderer Aspekt natürlich bei der bei der Versorgungslage ist ähm eine irgendwie
hatte ich so spontan so ein bisschen angenommen und vielleicht äh viele andere
auch das oh mein Gott, äh die sind jetzt im Krieg und alle sitzen jetzt irgendwie im Keller und äh warten, dass die Russen kommen oder sind an der Front und versuchen die Russen aufzuhalten.
Ein paar äh tatsächlich äh zum Beispiel ja in in Kiew hm ja da gehen die Leute äh,
weiter zur Arbeit so. Da funktioniert,
äh das Telefonnetz angeblich sogar die Taxi-App äh so.
Ich gehört und ähm ja und natürlich in in in großen Teilen des Landes geht das
zivile Leben auch einfach weiter. Da wird halt äh ja weiter auch ich sage mal produziert und und gearbeitet und ähm die Wasserversorgung und die Stromversorgung äh aufrechtgehalten
gehalten. Also ist jetzt nicht so, dass das Land jetzt sofort droht, auch zu verhungern. Äh äh sage ich mal, sondern
ja hm dass das Land funktioniert halt weiter,
so in in in weiten Teilen das das muss man halt auch bedenken und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass auch ukrainische Rüstungsfabriken.
Äh äh jetzt grade auf Hochtouren äh laufen und äh dass jetzt auch das Ganze nicht nur am am am
Tropf äh des Westens hängt, dass sie nur mit dem kämpfen können, was jetzt über die Grenze reinkommt, äh sondern natürlich auch selber
äh ja weiter äh Waffen und äh Munition produzieren.
So sieht diese Produktionsorte vor den russen russischen Luftangriffen ausreichend beschützt bekommen.
Wenn man sich das das anschaut, das Land ist einfach äh so groß und wenn wir auch bei vergangenen äh Kriegen
äh so gucken, wie dann wie wie schnell dann eigentlich auch selbst nach irgendwelchen größeren Bombenangriffen oder so, die Produktion wieder hochgefahren wurde in in
in Deutschland oder äh auch in in anderen
Ländern gehe ich mal davon aus, dass äh ja, dass da jetzt äh die die Wirtschaft oder auch die Rüstungsproduktion jetzt nicht zum Stillstand gekommen
und dass das auch nicht so einfach zu erreichen ist. Äh das ist das Ganze.
Klar, aber ich meine, die äh modernen ähm äh Raketen et cetera, die wurden ja nicht in in der Ukraine produziert.
Nee, nee, aber äh das ist ja auch
äh sagen nicht nicht nur, dass mit dem mit dem dort gekämpft wird, sondern die Ukraine hat ja auch ich sage mal, normale Artillerie und ähm ja äh eigene Panzer.
Und und solche Dinge und Minen und äh,
äh was auch was auch immer und äh das muss man eben auch noch in in Betracht ziehen, dass das,
ähm dass das auch weiterläuft während die Russen wahrscheinlich ein Großteil äh einfach von irgendwo von weit weit heranschaffen müssen.
Ja also,
Glaube sehr viel mehr kann man jetzt erstmal zur militärischen Situation so nicht sagen. Das ist so das äh wie sich das äh abzeichnet, also um's nochmal zusammenzufassen insgesamt,
Es gibt Veränderungen. Es
gibt's äh ein paar äh Gebiete, wo die Russen voranziehen können, aber umso mehr sie sich ausbreiten, umso größer werden auch ihre logistischen Probleme und grundsätzlich werden sie zurückgehalten und vor allem eben bei den
wichtigen großen Städten, Kiew und äh geht's nicht voran bei so strategischen
wie äh Sumi geht's nicht voran und die Fortschritte im Süden sind zwar da
aber da ist es generell noch schwierig und Dessert ist noch sicher
und ähm eine Verbindung nach Norden, sodass Kiev sozusagen auch vom Süden aus angegriffen werden könnte, dass äh liegt noch in weiter Ferne.
Also ob der Konflikte überhaupt so lange dauert, dass wir das noch sehen werden. Da bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so sicher, ohne jetzt hier in irgendeiner Form etwas ähm ankündigen zu wollen, was ich nicht weiß und wenn ich auch nicht einschätzen kann.
Aber generell ist der Eindruck auch, dass sich die dass die Intensität der Kämpfe auch äh langsam,
abnimmt äh im Moment und was nicht heißt, dass sie nicht nicht wieder auch auch mehr aufflammen können so und äh ja die
Russen haben sie halt in Positionen äh gebracht jetzt an an an vielen Stellen, aber das Ganze äh hat jetzt noch nicht irgendwie in der großen Offensive äh gemündet.
Wollen wir dann mal den wollen wir dann mal den zweiten Punkt aufgreifen, den wir angekündigt haben.
Und äh mal ein bisschen auf die internationale Ebene gehen.
Die Diplomatie ist natürlich am Kochen, es wird viel gereist und es wird viel ähm vorgeschlagen
Es gibt ja theoretisch auch Verhandlungen schon zwischen der Ukraine und Russland, aber ich glaube, die nimmt keiner äh ernst.
Dazu hat einfach Russland überhaupt nicht die richtigen Vertreter dort äh vor Ort. Was jetzt allerdings
Interessant war ist, dass äh die Israelis sich hier als Vermittler ins Spiel gebracht haben und schon drüber diskutiert wurde, ob man denn nicht in Jerusalem.
In irgendeiner Form in Verhandlung treten könnte?
Das ist vielleicht schon so ein bisschen die Vorbereitungen dadrauf, dass es dann irgendwann auch tatsächlich mal dazu kommen könnte.
Frage ist halt nur, was sind dann die Voraussetzungen, ne? Also inwiefern kann Russland sich dann hier als Platzhirsch äh.
Präsentieren oder äh.
Hat es die Ukraine eben auch geschafft, die Russen soweit zurückzudrängen, dass im Prinzip so ein fortgeschriebener Stellungskrieg ist, wo es nicht vorwärts und nicht rückwärts geht.
Für die Russen auch unter Umständen nicht rückwärts geht's auch noch so ein Aspekt, den man bei der militärischen Bewertung auch nochmal drin haben sollte. Das wird für die äh irgendwann auch nochmal ganz schön schwierig überhaupt wieder einen Rückzug einzuleiten.
Also genauso wie sie nicht vor können, können sie vielleicht auch irgendwann nicht wieder zurück.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall diese Diplomatie ist äh da und äh ja die Allianzen sind interessant. Also was natürlich auf der einen Seite klar ist, ist die NATO ist jetzt wieder.
Family und ähm ist irgendwie gut beisammen. Wir haben ja schon drüber gesprochen, sogar in Schweden und in Finnland. Wird jetzt über einen NATO-Beitritt gesprochen.
Und die einzigen Freunde, die die Russen so richtig haben, sind halt außer hier den äh Serben Syrien.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, wie man sonst noch nennen soll.
Richtig viele Freunde haben sie eigentlich nicht, also auch so Kasachstan und äh so die halten sich alle extrem
zurück. Keiner ist wirklich bereit da den Russen in irgendeiner Form zur Seite zu springen. Iran könnte man noch nennen, ja.
Ähm aber auch eher nur aus so einem totalen Eigeninteresse und von den großen Playern bin ich halt auch noch worüber auch relativ wenig berichtet worden ist, zumindest in Deutschland, ist Indien.
Die natürlich auch so ihre eigenen Interessen haben und äh ja sich glaube ich auch bei der UNO irgendwie enthalten haben.
Wäre natürlich Japan und so weiter voll Anti-Russland ist. Aber Indien interessiert erstmal derzeit so richtig keinen, sondern die große Frage ist, wie verhält sich China?
Chinas Verhalten war bisher.
Mix back, würde ich sagen. Ne, also sie haben sich natürlich auch enthalten bei der Verurteilung, bei der UNO und haben dann natürlich auch irgendwie dieses und jenes durchklingen lassen, also zwischen den Zeilen.
Kann man auch rauslesen, dass es den Chinesen eigentlich alles nicht so richtig in den Kram passt mit der Ukraine.
Also,
und die Chinesen zeigen da auch so ein bisschen zwei Gesichter auf der einen Seite ähm begrüßen sie äh natürlich grundsätzlich erst mal,
was irgendwie dann gegen den Westen oder gegen den gegen Amerika äh geht. Mhm.
Aber äh sie sind natürlich auch besorgt erstens um ihre eigene Wirtschaft,
welche äh welchen Einfluss das das dort hat, weil natürlich auch in in China man genauso auch Unruhen in der Bevölkerung fürchtet, wenn sich da die wirtschaftliche Situation,
zu sehr zum negativen entwickelt, dann mag
China-Sessionen grundsätzlich nicht. So
Also äh die sind halt schon eigentlich eher für territoriale Integrität. Weil äh natürlich wenn sich dann irgendwelche Landesteile da mit oder ohne Referendum
abspalten, schafft das natürlich unschöne Präzedenzfälle auch für China und das fürchtet halt äh China auch äh dass sich dann in China äh teilweise Landesteile,
trennen könnten angefangen, dass vielleicht Taiwan äh erklären äh könnte so. Nee, wir sind jetzt doch nicht mehr China. Ähm.
Aber auch äh generell ist hat China ja das riesige Problem, hm dass äh ein Großteil des Landes eigentlich defizitär,
So das heißt ein Großteil des Landes kostet einfach nur Geld ähm,
und muss halt aus anderen Landesteilen versorgt werden und da gibt es durchaus
auch äh sagen gewisse Bestrebungen, dass ich halt auch reiche Provinzen
abspalten könnten in in in China, weil die den wird's dann wesentlich besser gehen, wenn sie dann wie den
den äh ja den den den teuren Osten äh äh Chinas dann äh hinter sich lassen könnten. Das ist natürlich auch ein
Albtraum dann für die Chinesen. Aber äh.
Teure Osten. Der Osten ist teuer.
Nee, der Westen im in China ist im im im Süden und äh und Osten äh sind ja die ganzen reichen Provinzen und wenn man die abtrennen würde so,
dann hätten die auf einmal einen pro Kopf brutto Inlandsprodukt
was halt über dem, was weiß ich, von Südkorea liegt oder oder in in der Größenordnung von von Japan, ja? Also die würden sozusagen auf einen Schlag äh würde es denen da viel, viel besser gehen?
Ähm und äh von von daher ja
ist das äh halt auch äh so eine so eine Befürchtung, dass äh wenn anderswo in der Welt das das wieder zur Mode wird, dass sich da die Länder abtrennen, dass das dann für für China
äh auch auch nicht gut ist. So deswegen mögen die das erst mal grundsätzlich nicht und haben deswegen auch äh zum Beispiel die Krim immer noch nicht anerkannt. Äh so, dass die sich abgespalten,
hat und auch die anderen äh äh Teile nicht. Also die China offiziell äh hat nicht nur eine ein China-Politik äh sondern eigentlich eine Einukraine-Politik, wenn man das so will aus aus Gründen.
Eben. Ja ähm.
Und äh wo aber äh die Chinesen auch noch mal jetzt richtig gerade drüber abkotzen. Mhm ist.
Dass mhm ja durch diesen jetzt russischen Vorstoß, der,
so toll nicht gelaufen ist, jetzt erstmal die NATO wieder zusammengeschweißt wurde. Der Westen äh die Militärbudgets hochfährt und sich halt super,
einig ist, nachdem China sich auch so darüber gefreut hat,
ähm und das eigentlich ausnutzen wollte, dass die NATO sich da so langsam verstreitet und das ist irgendwie uneinheitliche einen Kurs bei, bei Sanktionen äh gibt,
und ähm und außerdem der langsame.
Fortschritt von Russland, was ja als die zweitstärkste Militärmacht der Welt gegolten hat so äh und,
Wenn die Chinesen sich das jetzt angucken ähm so und vor dem Hintergrund, dass sie vielleicht,
Taiwan ähm militärisch erobern äh könnten. Das können Sie sich jetzt
auf absehbare Zeit einfach mal komplett knicken, weil,
ähm wenn in mein wenn selbst Russland wo die Eisenbahn da direkt alle bis an die Grenze führen mit seinen äh äh gewaltigen äh äh Truppen und äh Überlegenheit und.
Allem so eine Mühe hat, mit einem,
Land wie der Ukraine, was zwar groß ist, aber jetzt nicht so viele moderne Waffen hat und wenn man das dann vergleicht mit Taiwan.
Was halt bevölkerungsmäßig auch nicht,
ohne ist, aber eben über extrem viele moderne Waffen verfügt und sie Taiwan ja.
Über das Meer
angreifen müssten. Das heißt, da gibt's keine Eisenbahn, sondern die müssten irgendwie mit Schiffen alles darüber schaffen, ja? Wenn wir das jetzt vergleichst so, dann äh kann man davon ausgehen so für China ist jetzt,
Traum oder die die die Vorstellung äh davon jetzt vielleicht militärisch irgendwas in Taiwan erreichen zu können, ist jetzt erst mal.
Platzt, also zumindest für die nächsten 10 oder 20 Jahre. So war's das jetzt äh für für China. Ja also das das
äh so.
Okay gut, das ist ja natürlich jetzt eher an ihrer eigenen Schwächen äh erinnert worden, als dass ihnen die Russen jetzt konkret was verbaut hätten
Ne, aber wo sie, glaube ich, ihnen richtig auch äh schlecht in die Karten spielen, das ist was die ganzen Expansionspläne bezüglich Handelsrouten über die sogenannte neue Seidenstraße betrifft.
Weil das natürlich auch durch die Ukraine geführt hätte und äh entsprechend jetzt ein schwieriges Problem wird.
Mhm. Ja, das ist sicherlich ein Punkt, aber ich glaube, der entscheidende Punkt ist.
Dass es jetzt einfach auch einen sehr erschreckender Reality-Check äh war äh für die für die Chinesen. Ähm wie ähm
mühsam, militärische Operationen äh doch sind und die Chinesen sind da eher auch noch viel Risiko averser und äh mögen auch noch weniger Todes.
Opfer oder so und ich glaube
Wenn die sich das angucken jetzt grade in in in China einfach, dann sagen die okay, mehr da lassen wir jetzt mal. Da da müssen wir noch zehn oder 15 oder 20 Jahre äh militärisch aufrüsten, bevor wir uns da irgendwo
militärische Abenteuer leisten könnten.
Das da gehe ich mal fest von aus, dass das da gerade ähm durch die Köpfe der chinesischen Führung äh geht.
Trotzdem wird's nicht so einfach sein, dass die Chinesen in irgendeiner Form mit ins Boot zu bekommen. Also das äh ist ja so ein bisschen.
Die Frage, ne? Inwiefern kann man den Druck auf Russland auch noch erhöhen und ich denke, da wird sich jetzt China aber auch nicht so ohne Weiteres jetzt einfach missbrauchen lassen, weil sie natürlich ihre eigenen Interessen haben.
Auch Gaspipelines nach Russland nicht ganz so viele und das könnte man natürlich noch mal ausbauen, aber.
Das äh wird dauern aber grundsätzlich.
Ich weiß nicht wie viel ja die haben schon signifikant Grenze auch mit äh Russland.
Nicht unbedingt alles immer so ohne Weiteres zu ähm.
Einfach zu nutzen. Ich gucke gerade mal, da ist noch mal dazwischen. Dann haben sie aber noch mal.
Kasachstan und was ist denn hier eigentlich? Ah da gibt's noch so eine kleine Brücke zwischen Mongolei und China, aber da ist dadurch ganz schön ganz schön viel Gebirge. Also im Wesentlichen läuft das alles so über den Osten.
Und es gibt natürlich auch noch nach wie vor äh ja ich sage mal
territorial Konflikte zwischen Russland und und China, die äh Chinesen haben da auch immer noch nicht ganz verknust äh was ihnen äh da äh die Russen mal abgenommen haben.
Äh vor weiß ich nicht 1hundert Jahren oder so. Das hätten die auch gerne wieder.
Haben sich da auch gemeldet. Also es ist zwischen Russland und und China, das ist eher so eine ähm ja.
Einen Seite auf der einen Seite ja, so eine so eine,
Sympathie wegen totalitäres Regime andererseits traut Putin auch den Chinesen null äh über den über den Weg so und zurecht glaube ich auch.
Gut, die Frage bleibt natürlich, was kann China jetzt äh auf einem diplomatischen Parkett unter Umständen helfen oder zumindest kein Problem sein? Oder denkst du, dass das letzten Endes die Sache mit China nicht entschieden wird?
Also wir werden natürlich gucken, an welchen Stellen sie so einmal eigentlich Geld machen können ohne sich aber jetzt allzu sehr.
Der Gefahr auszusetzen, selber von Sanktionen,
ja überzogen äh zu werden. So eine Sache ist, dass sie zum Beispiel jetzt ausgeweitet haben äh die die Nutzung chinesischer Kreditkarten
die schon da waren. Da hörte ich auch, dass jetzt die in großer Zahl wohl ausgegeben worden sein und ähm das,
das alles so ein bisschen auch auf ein gewisses Maß an Vorbereitung äh hindeutet, dass man da das Russland da schon vielleicht äh.
Ja
plant hat oder erwartet hat, dass vielleicht äh Kreditkarten ähm westliche dann dann abgeschaltet werden oder den Plan vorgezogen hat und an solchen Stellen werden sie natürlich natürlich gucken, wo sie
einerseits
Geld verdienen können, ihre wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen ausbauen können, auf dem russischen Markt jetzt äh dort eintreten können, wo jetzt westliche Firmen weggefallen sind, aber alles unterhalb so einer Schwelle, äh wo sie dann den Zorn der Welt
auf sich ziehen als Blockadebrecher, weil das hat glaube ich die Chinesen auch so ein bisschen geschockt. Ähm mit welcher Intensität
jetzt äh der Westen äh diese Sanktionen äh rausgeholt hat, wo es im Übrigen jetzt
auch Stimmen äh gibt, dass da
auch mehr an Vorbereitung äh schon da war bei den Sanktionen so im im Vorfeld, dass man sich da auch überlegt hatte, denn was machen wir denn eigentlich, wenn wenn er jetzt einmarschiert und dass es da auch ein bisschen mehr Pläne gab ähm
als man so vermutet. Eine Sache, von der ich noch gehört habe, mhm ist, dass äh wohl Russland,
eine Antifaschismuskonferenz plant eine größere, ne zusammen mit China.
Und äh äh Indien sind glaube ich auch eingeladen äh so so dass es so ein bisschen äh die Befürchtung
äh gibt äh plus ein paar andere äh Länder, glaube ich auch genau, Iran könnte auch mit dabei sein und auch ein paar andere Länder und dass sie auf diese Weise versuchen wollen, äh so eine
Allianz dann äh gegen den Westen äh zu schließen, gegen die ganzen faschistischen Imperialisten, die wir alle sind.
Tolle.
Genau. Mhm.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, gucken wir, wenn wir mal so ein bisschen auf Russland selber.
Du hast sicher ein bisschen intensiver mit äh Putin irgendwie selbst auseinandergesetzten letzten Tagen, ne.
Ja, ja. Also ein.
Ziel war zu gucken, okay wie ist denn jetzt Putin eigentlich einzuschätzen, so was ist das eigentlich für ein.
Und insbesondere natürlich die Frage äh wird er jetzt kämpfen bis zum.
Bitteren Erfolg äh sage ich mal oder.
Bis zum Untergang oder wird da jetzt auf den roten Knopf drücken oder was was wird passieren, so wie wie kann man denn eigentlich seine Mentalität,
einschätzen und äh wie.
Gefährlich äh wäre jetzt tatsächlich eine militärische Konfrontation mit dem Westen. Wie sehr würde das äh jetzt ja
die Gefahr tatsächlich eines dritten Weltkriegs heraufbeschwören und da bin ich.
Von zwei verschiedenen Seiten äh rangegangen. Zunächst mal äh hatte ich halt versucht einzuschätzen, was ist denn da jetzt.
Psychisch los äh äh mit mit ihm, also was für ja auch immer gesagt, hat er jetzt irgendwelche geistes äh Krankheiten oder wird er jetzt wird er jetzt den Nil oder so, aber,
tatsächlich war dann meine Vermutung äh dass es sich eher um eine, ich sage mal,
klassische, wie es so schön heißt, affektive Persönlichkeitsstörung handelt, die er aber schon immer hatte, die verändert sich normalerweise dann nicht.
Im Laufe des Lebens beziehungsweise eine bestimmte Sorte nimmt dann eher ab, aber ähm dass er.
Eben.
Ja äh ein Psychopath ist ein krimineller Psychopath. Das klingt jetzt erstmal schlimmer als es ist, also Psychopath klingt jetzt erstmal schlimmer als es ist, weil die meisten Psychopathen sind halt.
Eher
harmlos und werden dann vom Beruf her ja typischerweise nicht äh Richter oder,
Arbeiten bei den bei den Medien oder werden Vertriebsleute oder Chirurgen und äh führen da einen ganz nützliches und funktionales Leben, aber ähm
Es gibt eben auch einen Teil oder ja die dann die dann einfach kriminell äh werden. Äh plus.
Äh
Habe ich mir dann angeguckt, was sind denn so typische auch dann kriminelle Denkmuster aus der aus der Kriminologie äh heraus und fand,
dass das auch ganz gut passte an an an Putin, an verschiedenen Stellen.
Ähm dass er offensichtlich ähnliche Denkfehler macht äh wie sie halt Kriminellen typischerweise zugeschrieben,
werden und nur um jetzt noch ein paar Beispiele zu nennen, das kann man sich dann auf Twitter äh angucken, aber äh eben ein so ein typischer äh Denkfehler
ist äh eine eine gewisse Art von Superoptimismus, die dazu führt, dass halt Fehlschläge äh verdrängt werden oder nicht gesehen äh werden.
Ähm einen.
Weiterer äh Punkt ist eher auf der Basis von Eindrücken und weniger auf der Basis von Fakten äh zu zu handeln, also dann äh eben eine eine,
deutlich verringerte Fähigkeit zur Selbstkritik und Selbstreflexion und Selbstoffenbarung hm
wobei letzteres naja, Putin hat ja auch einen Haufen Bücher äh geschrieben. Das ist jetzt zwar nicht so was wie mein Kampf dabei, aber äh ja ein bisschen was äh gibt's,
gibt's da auch wo er dann mal versucht hat so seine seine Denke äh zu offenbaren und vor dem Hintergrund.
Bin ich dann äh erstmal im ersten Schritt ja zu der Überzeugung gekommen, dass man Putin eher äh wie einen.
Mafia-Boss äh sehen muss so vom der vom vom Plättern, der halt so tut, als wäre er Politiker.
Ja oder ein ein Politiker spielt, aber in äh Wirklichkeit ja,
muss man sich ihn eher als kriminellen äh Mafiosi äh vorstellen, der ähm an der Spitze der
der größten Verbrecherorganisation steht und mit Atomwaffen äh äh bewaffnet ist. So erstmal keine wirklich,
gute Vorstellung, immer oh mein Gott, aber wenn dieses Muster so stimmt, dann,
ähm hätte er eine weitere Eigenschaft äh nämlich, dass bei ersten ernsthaften Anzeichen von,
Widerstand er sich relativ schnell äh zurückzieht. Also dann nicht weitermacht, so äh das Gefühl hat, es äh läuft,
äh tatsächlich signifikant schief und.
Das passt auch zu so einer grundsätzlichen Eigenschaft der die russischen,
Führern so zugeschrieben wird und Leni hat das wohl mal so beschrieben, dass äh na ja.
Ähm äh prüfe mit dem äh Bajonett äh so. Ähm wenn es sich weich anfühlt,
dann Stich weiter zu und äh wenn es hart ist äh dann verpiss dich. So.
Ungefähr ja und ähm
dieses also es deckt sich so von von von verschiedenen Seiten, dass äh ja auf der einen Seite äh eine eine wirklich
nicht nur hohe kriminelle Energie äh da ist, sondern eine bestimmte Art von System, was wir als als kriminell,
eigentlich ansehen, was im Wesentlichen auf Lügen, Korruption und und Gewalt basiert. Hm.
Dort dort vorherrscht und äh ja äh das daher eine,
gute Vorgehensweise wäre ihm äh wirklich hart Paroli zu bieten und äh dass er dann eher nicht eskalieren
wird, äh sondern äh dann eher,
zurückziehen oder oder klein äh beigeben wird, äh wenn wenn die Situation äh zu krass wird und diese Einschätzung teilen dann auch viele Experten so. Allerdings scheint mir das noch nicht so die Mainstream,
Überzeugung in der westlichen Politik oder im im ja jetzt von Präsident Biden oder oder auch generell von westlichen.
Führern äh zu sein, sondern da ist man sehr darauf bedacht, nicht zu eskalieren.
Ja und es ist auch schwierig zu beurteilen äh was jetzt die bessere Strategie ist. Ne also ich meine beides hat natürlich was für sich. Sagen wir mal so, mein Eindruck derzeit ist der.
Man will schon, Putin in die Schranken weisen? Ich glaube nicht, dass man jetzt generell zittert.
Also klar es herrscht eine gewisse Angst vor der Bevölkerung, die ist ja auch absolut nachvollziehbar, dem kann man sich auch nicht so ohne Weiteres entziehen, weil Eskalation heißt halt noch mehr Leute, die mit dem ganzen Scheiß eigentlich nichts zu tun haben würden halt ähm.
Schaden äh davon nehmen, ne und ähm das vermeiden zu wollen ist ja auch durchaus ein legitimes,
Ziel und kann eigentlich generell sagen so ah ja die da passt uns jetzt hier irgendwie nicht, da hauen wir jetzt mal alles drauf und jetzt äh uns doch egal wer dabei Schaden nimmt ähm
Das Dilemma, was wir natürlich die ganze Zeit damit haben, dass das ja zwangsläufig bedeutet, dass eben ähm.
Einer einfachen Betrachtung es so aussehen könnte, als würde man der Ukraine jetzt nicht helfen und die Zivilbevölkerung muss es ausbaden, dass sie definitiv.
Tut gerade, ja? Äh das ist natürlich ein Dilemma. So, nur wenn man sich dann eben in die Situation von so.
Ähm ja Staatsführern
äh mal versetzen möchte. Nicht, dass ich da irgendwelche Erfahrungen hätte, aber nur so versuche mir eben diese diese Perspektive vorzustellen. Dann ist es ja immer eine Abwägung von okay, was,
Was bringt uns jetzt am Weitesten und was hat das geringste Risiko? Ne, weil klar, Risiko will man vermeiden.
Kann man auch eingehen, aber generell ist ja erst mal gut, Risiko äh zu vermeiden.
Nicht weil man da jetzt irgendwie ähm sie nicht traut oder keinen Mut hat oder feige ist, sondern weil das ja auch eine Stärke sein kann. So und derzeit ist halt der Pfad, der.
Okay wir können sehr viel damit ausrichten, indem wir quasi unsere Lager und unsere,
an Waffen jetzt in diesen Konflikt reinkanalisieren und die gut ausgebildete vor Ort stehende ukrainische Armee damit stark machen. Das das setzt derzeit Russland am meisten zu
Und sie können auch keine Ausflüchte äh erfinden mit äh aber wir werden ja hier vom Westen angegriffen. So das ist so glaube ich primär erstmal die Perspektive.
Genau das ist äh sozusagen das sind sagen die zwei guten also zwei gute Gründe nicht zu eskalieren ist, dass man ähm,
einerseits die Einigkeit bewahren
möchte beziehungsweise in der Welt beziehungsweise nicht mir als Aggressor jetzt dastehen möchte
ähm als als Westen, sondern ja äh weiterhin.
Sagen auf moralisch auf dem hohen Ross äh äh verweilen äh äh möchte, so dass es, denke ich, äh so so eine Sache und die andere Sache ist, dass es eher äh Putins,
Strategie ist äh zu eskalieren
und einfach dem Westen versuchen Angst zu machen und äh so dann ähm auch eine Verhandlungslösung hinzubekommen und das droht halt natürlich
auch äh immer noch. Also da gibt es nach wie vor auch
Aussagen, äh diverser Leute, die davon ausgehen, dass äh wahrscheinlich irgendwas entweder im Baltikum äh passieren wird oder auf See und da braut sich ja jetzt auch äh,
ein bisschen was zusammen. Die USA haben ja jetzt zwei äh äh größere Raketen äh Kreuzer äh hingeschickt, die beide mit.
Glaube jeweils 80 Cruise Misules. Mh äh bestückt sind und äh ja Russland,
irgendwie auch äh einen flotten Verband da auflaufen lassen und das Finanzsystem gerade diverse äh Militärübungen. Dort statt, ach ja Deutschland ist auch mit zwei Kriegsschiffen
äh beteiligt. Ich glaube, Deutschland hat zwei Fregatten äh äh da jetzt jetzt auch äh im im Einsatz bei der Übung
und äh ja und die Russen eben offiziell machen so ein so ein Manöver äh angeblich auch lange angekündigt zum Schutz von Sankt Peters
und Kreuzen da mit äh ein paar Dutzend Schiffen von Sankt vor Sankt Petersburg äh auf und ab
äh während ja äh eine größere NATO-Verbände dann äh dort grade auch äh sich in der Gegend befinden, aber die halten wohl
noch äh äh eine Menge Sicherheitsabstand äh voneinander, aber das ist natürlich auch immer eine kritische Situation, wenn du so äh ja haufenweise Raketen äh Kreuzer dort äh jetzt
rumfahren hast ähm so. Mhm.
Plus die die Dänen äh glaube ich wollen äh wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe jetzt auch Flugzeuge nach Bornholm verlegen äh so wo die Russen gerade Riesen-Terz
machen äh so und drohen, dass wenn sie das tun und angeblich äh hätten äh sie versprochen dort irgendwie nie Kampfflugzeuge zu stationieren, aber äh ja also auch an den
äh so gibt's grade so Eskalationspotential und äh man,
Man wird sehen, also ungefährlich ist ist das ist das alles nicht äh da äh grade. Aber.
Nee, definitiv ist es nicht äh ungefährlich und ähm natürlich sind alle gerade mit sehr kurzer Lunte äh ausgestattet und deswegen muss man da eben auch so vorsichtig vorgehen. Ich.
Jetzt einfach nur mal sagen, die aktuelle Reaktion ist insgesamt ist hier keine.
Reden schwingen, aber mir erscheint es nachvollziehbar, sagen wir es mal so.
Kann derzeit auf nichts zeigen und sagen oh großer Fehler.
Da müsstet ihr euch jetzt gerade komplett anders verhalten. So wird das alles in die Katastrophe führen. Ich habe eher so den Eindruck ja.
Alles irgendwie halbwegs nachvollziehbar unter den.
Bedingungen, dass ich natürlich nicht ansatzweise die Informationsquellen habe, wie äh staatliche Entscheider das haben.
Kann derzeit keine grundsätzliche Zurückhaltung feststellen und so
so ein Laissez aller ja was gibt mich die Ukraine an? Sondern alle haben schon verstanden dass dass das jetzt quasi der Konflikt des 21. Jahrhunderts ist erstmal.
So, das ist das ist jetzt wirklich der absolute ähm zentrale, geschichtliche Punkt, an dem sich die Geschichte der nächsten 30 Jahre äh dran neu
orientieren wird voraussichtlich.
Und.
Habe jetzt im Hinblick auf ja welche, ich sage mal, wie ist denn die historische Dimension jetzt dieses Konflikts oder wie tickt,
äh Russland hatte unter einem FIFA hatte so einen Vortrag verlinkt äh den.
2018 mal ein Finisher äh Geheimdienstmitarbeiter oder Ex-Geheimdienstmitarbeiter, der ist jetzt Professor äh da an der an der Hochschule und der gilt halt
als sehr intimer Russland-Kenner äh hat wohl auch irgendwie noch vor dem Ende der Sowjetunion,
äh in Sankt Petersburg gelebt, ist da halt hingegangen, hat die Sprache gelernt und äh ja äh und hat.
In dieser einen Stunde ähm.
Wirklich mein Russlandbild äh nochmal doch sehr sehr erweitert und äh das Ganze macht auf einmal Riesensinn, auch
Putin macht vor dem Hintergrund einfach einen einen Riesensinn. Und.
Ist halt eine Stunde auf Finish mit äh Untertiteln, also da muss braucht man dann schon ein bisschen
hm ja um äh äh da durchzugehen, aber es sind halt unglaublich viele Informationen, aber ich will jetzt vielleicht mal äh so die die die Kerndinge versuchen hier an
anzusprechen. Ähm erst mal.
Also erstmal äh dachte ich ja schon äh so, dass das politische System in Russland basiert.
Auf Lügen, Korruption und Gewalt und das seit 5hundert Jahren, weil es im Wesentlichen ein mongolisches,
ist man sagen, das kam halt dann äh nach dem Zusammenbruch äh so der mongolischen Herrschaft äh dort hm waren's halt sehr sehr turbulente Zeiten und das war dann
einfach die Zivilisatorische Antwort äh auf,
diesen dieses Chaos und diesen Umbruch, das heißt einfach Lügen, Korruption und Gewalt waren halt,
die drei Mittel mit der eine gewisse Ordnung aufrecht erhalten wurde und dass eben seit 500 Jahren. Und wenn man sich jetzt,
anguckt, egal ob man jetzt die Zahlenherrschaft betrachtet, ob man jetzt dann die kommunistische äh Herrschaft.
Betrachtet dort oder jetzt Putin. Hm.
In den letzten 500 Jahren gab es maximal zehn Jahre Demokratie in Russland und man sich dann anguckt, okay.
Welche Leute sind denn dann groß geworden in den in den zehn Jahren? Sieht man aber das ist ein Großteil auch der russischen Bevölkerung
entweder geprägt worden ist vor diesen zehn Jahren Demokratie oder mittlerweile äh ja auch.
Seit ja im Grunde genommen, was seit seit 2000 seit 22 Jahren auch mittlerweile eine Generation herangewachsen ist in Russland, die äh nichts anderes als als Putin
erlebt hat.
Die so das Bewusstsein in der Bevölkerung scheint zu sein wegen ihm dieser 500 Jahre Erfahrung. Entweder.
Autokratie, starke Führung oder Chaos. Das sind so die beiden Dinge und dann lieber Autokratie als Chaos.
Und hm.
Die größere staatliche Organisation, die sich dann ausgeprägt hat, die sich dann auch, egal ob zar, Kommunisten oder jetzt Putin
äh herausgebildet hat und auch während der Demokratiezeit, die im Übrigen für viele auch nochmal eine Bestätigung war, dass
ohne,
einen starken, autokratischen Führer ist Russland und dem Volk schlecht geht, war eigentlich nur ja eine eine Bestätigung, dass dass das so wie das seit 500 Jahren gelaufen ist, eigentlich der richtige Weg ist.
Sieht im Prinzip so ein bisschen klassisch aus wie so einen ja ähm soll man sagen eigentlich einen einen feuderlistisches System so. An der Spitze der.
Große Führer, der.
König, Zar, ähm Generalsekretär, äh wie wie auch immer er gerade bezeichnet wird oder Präsident äh jetzt und.
Der hat halt gesagt, hält das Heft äh der Macht in der Hand. Ähm.
Darunter gibt es dann die sogenannten Bojaren. Das ist eben so.
Ja äh Gruppe von Fürsten könnte man auch sagen. Die,
aber äh nicht wirklich Macht haben, die rangmäßig.
Einfach direkt unter ihm äh äh stehen und äh jetzt nicht irgendwie wählen oder sonst irgendwas und die Bojaren äh werden dann.
Eben mit bestimmten,
lehen versehen äh mit Ämtern, mit Positionen und äh können sich dann eben aus den Bereichern oder mit dieser Position hängt halt dann,
ja der der Luxus zusammen, in dem man äh in dem man lebt, aber die können halt jederzeit.
Vom ja vom Chef äh so vom obersten Chef entzogen werden,
Da gibt's dann keinen keinen Anspruch äh äh drauf, das Ganze zu behalten. So das ist halt kein kein,
tun, äh in in dem in dem Sinne. Und selbst wenn äh
jetzt zum Beispiel diese Oligarchen, die im Prinzip auch bejahren äh oder die, die halt die modernen Bojaren äh sind. So, die haben zwar auf dem Papier ihr Vermögen, aber wenn
Putin jetzt entscheidet und das haben wir ja gesehen. So nee, du nicht, dann kriegen die das einfach weggenommen. Ja.
Ähm das Ganze wird dann auch nochmal ergänzt äh durch jetzt wieder eine extreme Verflechtung mit Religion.
Also äh und und die Religionsführer dort, die orthodoxen, sind auch,
massiv korrupt. Da gab's dann mal dieses so ein schönes Bild, mhm wo dann dort der oberste Patriarch.
Am Tisch saß und ein Foto gemacht wurde und äh man darauf auf diesem Foto eine 30.000 Dollar Uhr an seinem Handgelenk gesehen hat.
Woraufhin die dann wegretuschiert wurde, nur haben sie ja jetzt so schlecht wegretuschiert, dass die Spiegelung im Tisch immer noch zu sehen.
Von dieser Uhr.
Profis mhm.
Ja er aber, da muss man auch vorsichtig äh sein. Ähm weil.
Es gibt wohl ich sage mal zwei Arten von Propaganda.
Die die in Russland betreibt. Das eine ist,
so eine Plumpe offensichtliche Propaganda, wo eigentlich jeder merkt, äh dass das Propaganda ist und sich alle lustig machen, äh wie dumm doch diese Propaganda ist.
Während die wirklich intelligente Propaganda äh die klugen äh Dinge, die klugen Manipulationen laufen so, dass idealerweise die manipulierten nicht mal merken.
Äh wie sie manipuliert werden und.
Das, darunter fallen dann eben solche Dinge, ja letztlich die die Oligarchen, die dann in die Welt
ausgeschickt wurden und alle möglichen Leute dann bestochen haben und in der City of London.
Haufenweise gilt, abgekippt haben. Äh ist ist jetzt nicht auch äh hier äh äh Johnson in den Verdacht geraten äh gerade.
Der die ganze Tory-Partei hat äh relativ viel Geld äh an Parteispenden von Russen bekommen. Die haben's ja sogar geschafft, so einen Putin vertrauten in House of Lords äh zu platzieren. Also,
geht da auch sehr weit und die ganze City aufladen ist extrem
verflochten mit russischem Geld und die Zahl der sanktionierten Personen ist in UK halt sehr viel niedriger als äh in USA und Europa und der Schweiz.
Und gut in den USA haben sie ja nun auch Trump äh unterstützt auf unterschiedlichste Art und Weise mit mit den E-Mails und.
Äh äh dann dann auch mit mit Geld und dann äh haben sich ja ganz viele Russen auch in diversen Trump-Immobilien äh eingekauft mit,
Wohnungen und und und Eigentum und so. Das heißt.
Da gibt es nochmal eine eine Ebene sag mal von nenn's mal russischer Propaganda oder russischen äh Einfluss oder Manipulation äh die
möglichst beunsichtbar äh äh bleiben soll und wesentlich äh cleverer und äh wesentlich Sofistic da und auch
wesentlich gefährlicher ist. So.
Geht übrigens das Geld nach Dubai gerade, ne?
Okay.
Und äh so über.
Über den Umweg äh Krypto Krypto ja Krypto-Assets versuchen sie halt jetzt irgendwie Kohle darüber nach Dubai zu schmuggeln und dort dann irgendwie Immobilien äh zu kaufen. Also
Das ist schon wirklich ein eine korrup.
IC. So, ja dann noch weitere Dinge, die er gesagt hat so zur russischen Mentalität, dass äh man äh dort auch kulturell das Leiden zur Tugend erhoben hat.
Das heißt, äh
dass ja äh so diese immer wieder bewunderte widerstandsfähigkeit und Leidensfähigkeit äh die äh das russische Volk an den Tag äh zu legen scheint, liegt.
Daran, dass eben wenn du leidest, äh dann ja, ist das eine eine Tugend. Und je mehr jemand
leidet so, umso ja äh mehr soziale Anerkennung äh bekommt, ja.
Und äh was glaube ich dann auch ein Grund ist, warum.
Viele Russen dann in der Öffentlichkeit mit so einer Leidensmiene äh rumlaufen, ja. Ähm weil äh ja, das ist äh das ähm ist halt Status. So das ist halt also wer mehr leidet, hat
auf eine gewisse Arten einen höheren Status und außerdem scheinen die Russen auch seit.
Ja, sehr, sehr langer Zeit hm so etwas wie in zwei verschiedenen Realitäten
zu leben, die sie managen. Da ist einmal
die innere Realität, also die Realität am Küchentisch, wie es genannt wurde, was so im privaten Raum besprochen wird und dann gibt es eben die externe Realität, was,
öffentlich und hm ja äh in den in den Medien und äh.
Eben zwischen jetzt äh den den.
Familien oder außerhalb der der Familie äh dann dann besprochen wird und diese zwei Realitäten ähm ja werden dann, je nachdem,
wohl recht gut gemanaged und auch äh wenn sie
total widersprüchlich und konträr äh sind, ist das halt überhaupt kein Problem, weil so ist das halt. Ja, also man hat halt einfach diese diese zwei Realitäten.
Ja hm und das Ganze äh jetzt,
schlägt sich dann auch so ein bisschen auf die die gesamte.
Politische Situation äh in in in Russland oder die die die Sicht, wie sich die Russen in der Welt sehen. Ähm und.
Russland wird praktisch immer belagert. So so sehen die Russen das so und,
ja, wie realistisch das ist. Äh man sehen tatsächlich objektiv gesehen, wenn man sich anguckt.
An wie viel Grenzen jetzt wirklich Gefahr droht, ist das jetzt nicht so wild so die der Großteil der Nachbarn,
stellt nicht nicht wirklich eine Gefahr dar, aber aus Sicht der Russen ist Russland immer von Feinden umzingelt, die das Land äh besetzen und zerstören wollen und das ist natürlich ein paar Mal.
Auch durchaus passiert, weil sie haben dann auch nicht so viele,
jetzt ja natürliche Grenzen oder oder oder Barrieren ähm,
Und dann na ja, gab's ja schließlich Napoleon und dann äh gab's die Niederlage im Ersten Weltkrieg und dann gab's, ja, die den Zweiten Weltkrieg, wo die Deutschen relativ weit
vorgestoßen sind für russischen Verhältnisse, den russischen Geschmack und das hat sie natürlich nur bestätigt.
Und eigentlich, das hat auch so ein Statement von Putin, was dazu passt. So eigentlich leben sie.
Entweder in einem heißen Krieg oder in einem kalten Krieg, sondern anderen Zustand gibt es eigentlich gar nicht und.
Ja und Putin hat deswegen gesagt, dass Russland den Kalten Krieg auch gar nicht verloren hat, weil er nie geendet ist.
Ja? Das ist so eine Aussage von von Russland so und äh so äh gibt es eben tatsächlich in Russland einen so ein neurotisches Gefühl der Unsicherheit, nämlich,
Die NATO wird angreifen, früher oder später wird die NATO angreifen. So und.
Das macht sie gewissermaßen irgendwie blind für die Logik des Verstandes.
Aber extrem sensibel für Logik der Macht. Ja? Das heißt, ja,
logische Argumente und so alles schön und gut, aber am Ende entscheidet nie, wer
dann wirklich ja einfach mit mit harten physikalischen Fakten wäre einfach mehr Waffen und mehr Truppen äh äh am am Boden hat. So der
äh wird halt die Oberhand äh behalten.
Ja, also es wird äh interessant bleiben. Also ich habe so den Eindruck, es wird.
Wahrscheinlich auch in den nächsten Tagen ähnliche Nachrichten geben und es ist so ein bisschen ein äh.
Ja, also ein ein wie sagt man, so ein.
Brauchungskampf so ein wer als erstes, wer aber als erstes so ein bisschen die Ressourcen ausgehen.
Hm ja ähm.
Und es ist noch nicht genau absehbar, bei wem das jetzt in welcher Form das erste Mal so sein wird.
Naja, am Ende äh also wenn man jetzt das das Big äh Picture äh sehen, dann äh sieht sich
Russland ja eher im Kampf mit der NATO und die Ukraine ist ja äh nur ein Teil äh vom vom äh Kampf
gegen die NATO und äh äh und das,
musst du natürlich auch auch immer irgendwo mit mit ein Einbeziehen ist die.
Ja, Ukraine so ein bisschen in eine Mittel zum Zweck ist oder gerade nun mal dummerweise das Land ist, äh was aus russischer Sicht jetzt äh zwischen äh.
Die Mühlsteine äh äh geraten ist. So zwischen Russland und und und die NATO. Aber ähm.
Das war dann auch mal so eine Frage äh so wie wie imperialistisch,
ist eigentlich Russland so grundsätzlich wie imperialistisches äh Putin und da war dann die Analyse, okay, Russland ist genauso imperialistisch wie die USA.
So möchte sich sagen auch ausbreiten gerne und.
Außerhalb äh ihre Macht äh projizieren, aber aus ganz anderen Gründen.
So. Die USA will Rohstoffe oder Öl oder irgendwas äh so. Während äh Russland.
Des Imperium wegen der Sicherheit haben will, wegen.
Der Angst so, also sozusagen eher so ein Imperium aus Angst. So, wir brauchen halt irgendwie ein bisschen was um uns rum
so so ein Puffer und das scheint tatsächlich auch so ein Grundbedürfnis der der Russen äh zu sein.
Ja äh und die zweite Sache, auch noch mal so eine interessante Sicht, die die mir selber noch gar nicht bekommen kommen wäre. Das ähm,
Russland, Europa retten will. So weil,
der Meinung ist, ja Europa weiß nicht, wie sehr es eigentlich in Gefahr ist
so und es hat sich ja in der Vergangenheit gezeigt so, dass irgendwie Napoleon äh oder Hitler oder der Islam oder wer auch immer äh so droht,
Europa.
Ähm ja ähm wie auch immer unter unter seine Knute zu bringen oder die die Amerikaner in dem in dem Fall und Russland sieht sich also so ein bisschen als äh Retter Europas
und auch äh
insgesamt äh so als äh weiß ich nicht Schutzherr des der Slaven äh jetzt ähm so.
Und.
Wenn man ja wenn man sich das das jetzt auch noch mal überlegt, das passt natürlich dann alles ganz gut jetzt zu zu dem, was, was, was, was Putin.
Da möchte. Ähm weißt du eigentlich ob Schröder sich jetzt mit Putin getroffen hat?
Angeblich hat er einen Termin gehabt, aber ich habe nichts gehört, ob da irgendwas bei rausgekommen ist. Ich habe da auch ehrlich gesagt so meine Zweifel, dass da irgendwas bei rauskommen kann.
Weil,
Nehme ich das von diesen Bojaren äh äh gehört habe ähm so ist Schröder bestenfalls,
sagenden äh was aber auch bedeutet äh ja, der hat im Grunde genommen nichts zu melden.
Oder äh was halt auch äh auf der Agenda äh steht und und zu diesem Thema intelligente Manipulation äh gehört, ist äh Nutzung nützlicher Idioten.
Und in dem Zusammenhang fiel mir dann ein, als ich das das hörte, hm Schröder.
Wahrscheinlich. Also äh das heißt in in dem Zusammenhang äh ja würde ich vermuten, dass äh Putin.
Schröder eher als nützlichen Idioten äh betrachtet. Ja, hm.
Und vielleicht jetzt noch noch als als als als letzter Punkt äh zu ähm sagen zum zum Russland verstehen, der vielleicht.
Auch wichtig ist, ähm nämlich der Umgang mit der Wahrheit. Hm.
In Russland gibt es auch einen etwas anderes Konzept von Wahrheit und Lüge und es gibt eben.
Auch äh zwei verschiedene äh Worte äh für äh Wahrheit äh und wohl drei für Lügen. Das habe ich jetzt noch nicht nachrecherchiert. Das sagte der der der Finne, aber es gibt dann einmal.
Prav da. So das ist so eine Wahrheit.
Aber nicht die absolute Wahrheit äh und äh eher auch eine Form von taktischer Wahrheit und es kann wahr sein oder auch nicht wahr sein. So, das heißt, da ist so eine sozusagen immer eine gewisse
Unsicherheit mit verbunden. Und dann äh gibt es noch äh äh etwas äh ja das heißt,
Was wie ist Tina? Ähm das ist eher dann die absolute Wahrheit oder die.
Absolute Sicherheit oder so wahr wie möglich, weil tatsächlich das Gegenteil von Lüge. Und ähm.
So bei bei Lügen äh gibt's eben, ich weiß nicht genau, wie das ausgesprochen wird, aber so. Und hm,
das ist so was, was man äh ja wie heißt das den Deutschen im Englischen? Es ist White Light ähm ähm,
Wenn man äh zu sagen, nö, nö, ähm ja, also äh Lüge, die man halt äh äh begeht, um äh jetzt sich aus einer peinlichen Situation äh äh zu.
Retten oder äh einfach ja ähm keine Ahnung die Mutter nicht zu sehr äh sich sorgen zu lassen oder so, sondern eine eine Lüge einfach die.
Eine Notlüge, wenn man wenn man so will, ne? Genau, so eine gewisse Art von Notlüge. Ja. Ähm aber hm.
Es gibt eben dann äh auch noch äh diese hm diese taktische Wahrheit, die äh oder taktische Lüge, sage ich mal, ähm.
Die äh so funktioniert, dass hm.
Wenn du hast halt die Ingroup.
So und du hast halt das das Außen, so die Öffentlichkeit oder andere Gruppe und hm.
Wenn du,
sagen die anderen also nach außen lügst, dann äh wird es von innen nicht als,
Lüge äh gesehen, dann bist du sozusagen kein Lügner, der die Unwahrheit sagt, sondern das ist etwas, was völlig akzeptiert ist gegenüber Außenseitern und wo man.
Als Insider,
auch weiß, dass es sich um eine Lüge handelt und weiß, dass es sich um eine taktische Lüge äh äh handelt oder nur um eine ähm nach außen und deswegen ähm,
bist du auch gar nicht diskreditiert nach nach innen und gilt's gilt's eben nicht als Lügner und dieses Konzept,
kennen wir so bei uns nicht, wenn du dich halt hinstellst als als Politiker äh und irgendetwas sagst ähm.
Ja und hinterher stellt sich raus, das war eine Lüge, dann äh wirst du halt eine Lügner, aber.
Russland, wenn du jetzt sagen wenn wenn jetzt der russische Präsident, wenn jetzt Putin hm die Welt anlügt so, dann.
Ist das völlig verzeihbar oder dann dann ist das eben keine nicht nicht wirklich eine Lüge oder macht ihn nicht zum Lügner. Ja?
Das äh hat dann Lenin glaube ich auch betont äh so dass dass es halt völlig legitim ist. Hm.
Ausländer anzulügen oder den Westen anzulügen, äh dass das dass das eben eben völlig in Ordnung ist. Ja.
Und hm dann.
Gab's nochmal die Vorhersage äh dort oder wie gesagt ist von von 218 die Annahme des Putin bis 2024 im Amt bleibt.
Und dann äh sagen von einem der Prinzen abgelöst,
äh wird und damals äh waren halt irgendwie zwei äh zwei Prinzen im Gespräch.
Äh Alexei Juman und äh Jevgeni Sinizev, aber der ist halt verstorben bei einer Arktis,
weil einem Kameramann hinterher gesprungen ist, der da irgendwie abgerutscht ist und ins Wasser gefallen und dann sind halt beide äh ja äh.
Getötet worden und hm woran man mhm eben diese Prinzen erkennen kann. Äh die müssen halt Helden sein.
So und die kriegen dann auch äh vorher so der der hat glaube ich schon
was nicht einer von beiden hat schon den offiziellen Heldenstatus verliehen bekommen und äh ich wollte demnächst mal gucken, wer denn sonst noch so jetzt offiziell als als Held der russischen Republik gerade gilt. Das heißt
Da könnte man dann dann sehen, dass es dann halt äh möglicherweise einen einen Putin äh Nachfolger und
Äh da wird dann aber auch sichergestellt sein, dass es da eine Kontinuität gibt und dass Putin dann auch äh kein Ärger oder oder keine Probleme
äh kriegt, sondern dann weiter äh beschützt wird. Da wird's dann quasi
dann äh einen Wechsel an der Spitze äh geben. Ähm so dass zumindest äh.
Ist ist der ist der Plan oder so, so würde es wahrscheinlich auch äh laufen, wenn äh ja früher nicht irgendwas Schlimmes passiert.
Also als jemand, der
Wie ich ja schon in der Ursprungssendung äh gesagt habe, eigentlich von der ganzen slawischen Welt und speziell äh Russland eigentlich relativ wenig Ahnung hat, ähm lerne ich natürlich jetzt auch eine Menge dazu.
Grade was diese ganzen historischen und gesellschaftlichen Analysen äh betrifft. An der Stelle vielleicht auch noch mal ein äh Tweet verlinken, der so eine Art super
super Fred aufs Red ist und zwar von Kamel Galev.
Hast du sicherlich auch schon ein paar von äh gelesen, aber sicherlich auch noch nicht alle. Ähm ist äh.
Ich meine, der eine Picking University ähm,
arbeitet und äh sehr lange, sehr ausführliche, sehr wohl geschriebene äh Srets auf Twitter äh veröffentlicht zu allen möglichen Aspekten,
zwei dieser Fritz ähm kann man an der Stelle auch noch mal mitverlinken. Einerseits ähm.
Erläuterung oder seine Perspektive dadrauf, wer eigentlich die Macht hat in Russland.
Und dann auch noch mal spezifisch, welche Rolle die Armee in dem Ganzen spielt. Und man nimmt ja gerne Russland so als Militärmacht war.
Und würde dementsprechend dann auch sagen, das Militär hat einen großen Einfluss.
Eine These ist die mitnichten so. Ganz im Gegenteil, das Militär ist eher untergeordnet und das ist nicht nur so, weil es irgendwie.
Historisch so gewachsen ist oder so, sondern weil das irgendwie auch das Prinzip des Systems Putins und vielleicht auch.
Russischen Tradition sozusagen äh wie sich diese ganzen Systeme entwickelt haben entspricht. Die äh im Wesentlichen bedeutet, dass das machtvollste Instrument und das eigentliche Machtinstrument in Russland ist halt die Staatssicherheit.
Die Staatssicherheit hat quasi die Kontrolle über alles und alles, was in irgendeiner Form eine Bedrohung sein könnte für dieses System dieser Staatssicherheit.
Das wird auch klein gehalten und dementsprechend wird auch die Armee kleingehalten. Deswegen ist die Armee auch nicht sozusagen entscheidend und äh nicht gut ausgestattet und hat auch keinen großen Status.
Verlinkt da unter anderem einen Clip, der äh vor kurzem in ähm im Fernsehen, im russischen Fernsehen, die wo so.
General war, aber äh irgendein äh russischer Militär höheren Grades da irgendwie äh in der Fernsehsendung wollte, dass es irgendwie so eine Schweigeminute gibt für für die gefallenen russischen Soldaten und dann vom,
dem Moderator dieser Sendung zusammen geschrien wird, irgendwie was er sich denn hier irgendwie herausnehmen würde und äh,
doch einfach alle hier ihre Befehle auszuführen und überhaupt und was soll denn das alles?
Schon mal ganz interessant gezeigt. Da haben so Situationen, die man sich hier überhaupt nicht vorstellen kann. Oder auch in den USA zum Beispiel nicht, ja, wohl das Militär ja schon fast Heiligenstatus hat.
Und das ähm auch dieses System der begünstigten, ja und die sozusagen ähm überhaupt quasi das ganze Geld abziehen.
Und unter Putin schalten und walten können, wie sie wollen.
Das auch nach einem ähnlichen Prinzip läuft, nämlich dass eigentlich die Leute, die quasi.
Am meisten so seine Kronies sind und am meisten äh von ihm gestattet bekommen, irgendwie das ganze Geld einzunehmen und letzten Endes nach seiner äh Pfeife tanzen und er sie aber auch dann tanzen lässt, dass die halt.
Diejenigen sind, die halt einfach super korrupt sind, aber weil sie halt auch so super korrupt sind, eigentlich auch keine.
Fähigkeiten besitzen. Ja, also die können die können nicht viel. Die sind halt einfach so äh äh korrupt und einfach gestrickt. Die könnten jetzt gar keine besonders komplexen Dinge führen.
Und deswegen sind das halt so diese großen ähm.
Industriekomplexe wie eben Ölproduktion, Gasproduktion, ja Gasproben und und und äh.
Heißt nochmal die Ölfirma ist das Rossneft. Nee, das ähm was war das? Komm mal ein bisschen durcheinander. Egal, also auf jeden Fall die äh auf diesem Level.
Weil das keine komplexen Industrien sind, ja? Das ist das ist nichts, das ist kein.
Außergewöhnliches Engineering mit komplexen äh Strukturen oder so, sondern ist relativ klar, was man da macht. Da schließt man um so ein Ölfeller, da kommt das Öl raus, kommt irgendwie in Tanks rein, zack, bumm, Raffinerie, fertig, aus. So. Das ist irgendwie alles noch behandelbar.
Und auf der zweiten,
Ebene da drunter kommen dann halt so die komplexeren äh Industrien ja was weiß ich Waffenbau äh et cetera.
Die wirklich komplizierten Sachen, was weiß ich, wenn jetzt jemand irgendwie in IT unterwegs ist, Softwareunternehmen irgendwie, wo halt äh wirklich äh Ingenieurstum gefragt ist und wo auch,
Führer gefragt sind, die also wirklich auch was von der Materie verstehen und die in der Lage sind, so komplexe Produkte zu produzieren
sind dann halt in dieser ganzen Hierarchieebene schon so eher auf Level drei.
Können einfach auch gar nicht viel Geld verdienen und werden dann halt auch schnell irgendwie ausgenommen. Du hast ja neulich, glaube ich, schon dieses Beispiel erwähnt mit da wird dann die Produktion mal eben nach Tschechien ausgelagert.
Ja, ja. Mhm.
Weil weil weil diese diese Branchen sich da einfach auch gar nicht groß äh wehren können beziehungsweise sie auch bewusst kleingehalten werden, weil es soll halt niemand aufsteigen und viel Geld verdienen.
Der intelligent genug ist, um solche komplexen Operationen durchzuführen. Weil das dann eben wieder eine Bedrohung als Bedrohung angesehen wird für diesen Staat.
Ja? Du darfst nur da oben wirtschaften, wenn du irgendwie so halbwegs bräsig unterwegs bist und äh ja im Wesentlichen ist grad mal schaffst irgendwie so eine so eine Ölproduktion am Laufen zu halten, um ein bisschen Gas,
so und und nur da ist dann irgendwie Zugang zu den allerhöchsten Schichten äh erlaubt.
Ja und die sozusagen die die Qualifikation für höhere Ämter ist dann halt im Wesentlichen Loyalität.
So äh zum Beispiel hat äh Putin ja auch erfahren irgendwie seinen ehemaligen ja Judo.
Sparrings Partner halt zum Drei-Sterne-General gemacht, der halt als Ausbildung
äh irgendwie äh Dreher gelernt hatte. So das ist halt das
das Ganze und da war halt auch irgendwie dieser dieser Finne so ein so ein bisschen sauer er meinte irgendwie okay er hat irgendwie äh sechs Jahre äh äh Hochschulstudium absolviert und äh ja ist dann
als ähm ja äh ist das äh äh.
Ähm Oberstleutnant ähm Oberst äh entlassen worden und hat's nicht mal bis zum General geschafft und sondern Dreher, der halt äh als Hauptqualifikation äh eher Freundschaft mit mit,
Putin und und Judo mitbringt, äh wird dann eben Drei-Sterne-General. Und auch noch zur zur Macht äh Situation
Ich glaube, wo halt sehr viel Macht äh auch äh drin äh äh steckt, ist halt die sind die Nationalgarde.
Das sind so die die inneren Truppen des Innenministeriums oder waren irgendwie die inneren Truppen und gilt eben ja als eines der wichtigsten innenpolitischen Machtinstrumente der Regierung.
Also ich kann euch nur raten, euch dieses Retz von diesem Kamel Galaf durchzulesen. Das ist wirklich super insidevoll. Ähm ich hab's jetzt hier gerade mal die ganze Liste mal durchgescrollt bis zum heutigen Tag.
Hat der irgendwie 42und solche produziert seit ähm warum ging das los? Seit dem 28. Februar.
Und jeder ist irgendwie dreißig, 40 ähTweets lang, also da ist man wirklich ganz schön lang am Scrollen, aber es es lohnt sich äh enorm, ne? Und ähm.
Im Übrigen ist auch seine Grundthese die, dass dass Russland diesen Krieg verlieren wird.
Aus eben einer ganzen Reihe von Argumenten, die er dann in diesem Tritz auch wirklich ausführlich darlegt. Ähm einfach, dass.
Ist halt einfach nicht resilient. Jetzt in dieser Situation, die Armee ist nicht in der Lage, den Widerstand der Ukrainer lange ähm.
Etwas entgegenzusetzen. Also irgendwann werden sie sich da einfach komplett äh verfahren. Die Sanktionen des Westens werden einfach die russische Wirtschaft wirklich ähm.
Ans.
Ans Limit und darüber hinaus bringen. Der Braintrain äh ist enorm. Der Schaden ist einfach äh vielfältig und auch wenn es jetzt derzeit noch so den Eindruck hat, dass das alles irgendwie
Empire und und keiner kommt dagegen an und Atomwaffen und überhaupt und oh Gott Putin ja und alles so übermächtig und morgen ist hier Atomkrieg.
Klar, es kann sein, dass hier noch viel Eskalation stattfindet, aber Eskalation können auch die anderen.
Und so stark sind sie am Ende nicht und sie haben eine extrem verletzliche Wirtschaft.
Die es einfach aus diesen genannten Gründen auch nicht geschafft hat eigene Strukturen hinzubekommen und in der Lage ist ihre Basics zu äh zu erzeugen. Haben wir ja hier auch schon ein paar Mal.
Erwähnt, ja, dass es also an an an so grundlegenden Sachen wie Schmierstoffen und Kugellagern äh schon scheitert, dass sie überhaupt in der Lage sind, ihre Produktionsketten autark ähm.
Aufrechtzuerhalten, ne. Ich meine, ich weiß noch, wie wir hier am Anfang der Corona äh Krise auch das Gejammere dann sehr groß war,
äh Deutschland ja nicht mehr so die basic Komponenten für Medikamentenproduktion herstellt, weil das irgendwie alles in äh
in Indien ist und wenn irgendwie Indien wegen der Coronakrise komplett auf Nationalversorgung umschaltet, wäre dann schön doof dastehen, ne. Dass man da jetzt auch wieder umgeschaltet hat und diese dieser ganze Gedanke der Autarkie.
Ähm ja und Vorbereitung für Krisen äh wieder eine andere Bedeutung bekommt,
russische Wirtschaft ist an der Stelle überhaupt nicht zu retten. Also die haben also weder weder haben sie in irgendeiner Form überhaupt eine Produktion ihrer äh ihrer grundlegenden Dinge. Sie hängen einfach komplett vom Ausland ab.
Noch sind sie halt derzeit kulturell.
So aufgestellt, dass sie da auch äh innerhalb kürzester Zeit irgendeinen Turnerraum schaffen, weil sie einfach die Leute gar nicht halten können, weil niemand.
Der so eine Produktion von solchen wichtigen Dingen aufrechterhalten würde in dem System, in dem was derzeit in Russland herrscht, auch nur produzieren äh können könnte oder wollte.
Ähm mhm und äh das das das passt halt äh auch ganz äh gut,
zu einem auch noch einem Punkt, nämlich der die die Frage, okay, unter welchen Bedingungen sagen könnte Putin gestürzt werden? So ähm und
da gibt es tatsächlich aber nur sagen ein Dingen also waren russische,
Führer äh gestürzt werden, nämlich wenn sie schwach erscheinen.
So. Das ist das ist der der einzige Punkt. Solange und und das weiß Putin natürlich und solange sich äh Putin als stark erweist so oder den Eindruck erwecken kann,
stark zu sein. So droht ihm auch keine Gefahr durch Volksaufstände und auch keine Gefahr äh durch äh seine Bojaren oder wer auch,
immer. So aber in dem Moment äh wo er irgendwo ja Schwäche äh äh so schwach aussieht. So kann man relativ sicher sein.
Dass er dann relativ schnell weg vom vom Fenster ist, weil dann erfüllt er nicht mehr diesen
Prototypen oder diese diese Eigenschaften, die man eben von einem russischen Führer erwartet und wenn man sich das auch historisch rückwirkend anguckt, wann es
eben immer so Führungswechsel gegeben hat, dann äh ja äh war das immer was weiß ich, Boris Jelzin, äh der halt
einfach sehr sehr schwach ausgesehen hat äh zum zum Beispiel.
Oder äh ja dann äh Gorbatschow äh der eben auch sehr schwach ausgesehen hat und wo sich dann einfach dann die die Provinzfürsten mal eben überlegt haben, nee
so der der der Mann ist es nicht
und so kann man halt wirklich zurückgehen und äh immer eben ja und beim beim Zaren äh war's halt der dann den Krieg verloren hat. Ähm
und ähm sagen dann äh wer war denn wer war denn dran? Äh sagen vor Boris äh.
Äh äh äh nee Frau Gorbatschow äh meine ich, außer irgendwie der war Zwischenzeit an Dropphof und äh Breschnew, genau.
Und äh das war halt äh ja der Rückzug aus dem Afghanistan äh Krieg, der ihn halt schwach hat aussehen lassen und
äh da äh wurde er eher gestürzt. Also das
glaube ich finde ich auch äh irgendwie recht recht plausibel, das das macht Sinn und.
Einer als als ähm letztes Ding jetzt hm zu dem Ganzen äh Kleptokratie System wie das funktioniert. Also auch da gibt es ein Gesetz,
also ein ungeschriebenes Gesetz, an das sich alle halten müssen, so ähm und zwar du darfst stehlen.
Aber erstens, nicht mehr als dir zusteht, so deinem Rang nach, also nicht zu viel und nicht von den falschen.
Ja, dann bist du raus. Aber solange du äh halt nur so viel nimmst, wie dir irgendwie ungefähr deinem Rang nach zusteht.
Und äh ja, solange du nicht von den falschen äh Stiels, so ist alles okay und da gibt's eben auch Beispiele dann, wo dann die Oligarchen einfach mal abserviert äh wurden, äh weil äh sagen
Putin
das Gefühl hatte, äh so okay, der hat's der der hat sich jetzt zu viel genommen. So viel so viel steht ihm nicht zu und dann bist du raus. Äh wenn du gegen das Gesetz verstößt.
Wo ich auch nochmal drauf gestoßen bin, sagte der Name Magnitzki etwas?
Nitzky-Act.
Ja genau und das ist dann ich ich habe dann auch nur mitbekommen so als das passiert ist so okay dass da irgendwie in den in den USA ähm.
Irgendjemand
aus der Elite offenbar umgebracht wurde, der gut vernetzt war und gute Freunde hatte und äh deswegen halt äh ja ähm.
Wie ich sage mal die die Milliardäre oder ein Milliardär äh äh in den in den USA halt äh Druck gemacht hat. Mhm das äh.
Das geahndet wird und hm habe mir.
Ähm William Browder.
Ja ja und äh genau.
TED Talk äh von ihm zu dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Ja, ja, ist äh sehr, sehr kompakt und äh sehr gut äh dargestellt und der der Browder ist halt
Relativ jung hatte genau das richtige Alter und die richtige Ausbildung und den richtigen Background irgendwie sein Vater war im Übrigen äh Chef der kommunistischen Partei in den USA ja,
So und hat natürlich hat hat riesen Ärger gekriegt und er muss sagen, hat dann als als äh äh Akt der Rebellion, hat sich dann überlegt, okay, wenn äh
Ähm dann werde ich eben großer Kapitalist und äh aber wegen halt auch äh Russland und so, weil sich das da gerade öffnet, äh hat er sich überlegt, werde ich halt größter Kapitalist
in
in Russland in der Sowjetunion erstmal äh und dann in in Russland wird da auch erstmal riesigen Erfolg, hat halt einen Fond aufgelegt und Milliarden äh äh gemacht.
Aber hat dann deswegen auch irgendwann ähm ja.
Sagen den Zorn, Putins äh erregt, weil wie gesagt.
Er war halt, hat sich halt nicht wie so einen Bojar verhalten, sondern ja, hat einfach genommen,
Wasser kriegen kann. So äh beziehungsweise,
mit mit mit seinem äh Fond halt sehr viel Erfolg gehabt und dann kam wohl und und der Deal angeblich, weiß ich nicht, den den Putin
mit den Oligarchen hatte, äh irgendwann, als er die versammelt hat, hat gesagt irgendwie okay, äh aber 50 Prozent für mich.
So. Das heißt und und er hat gesagt wieso soll ich jetzt Putin 50 Prozent äh abgeben, dann kann ich das ja irgendwie gleich sein lassen und hat dann gesagt, nee, dann mache ich halt den Laden dicht.
Und äh dann äh ja äh sind sie da.
Erstmal eingeritten mit äh allen möglichen äh ja Truppen sage ich mal äh jetzt also mit Polizei und und und allem und haben hm wollten ihm dann
die ganzen Firmen abnehmen, aber er war schneller und hatte die halt schon verkauft. So
Aber dann, was dann passiert ist, ist äh bevor er die verkauft hatte, hatte er noch mal 250 Millionen Dollar an Steuern.
Bezahlt und,
dann äh wurde sagen im Namen seiner Firma dann äh sagen wieder eine Steuerrückerstattung von 250 Millionen. Hm
vorgenommen von jetzt ja Putins äh sage ich mal und ähm.
Er wollte nicht, dass das irgendwie durchgeht und hat dann dann eben den Magnickski
äh äh da ins Feld geschickt beziehungsweise ein riesen Aufriss gemacht auch über Medien und hat das eben alles öffentlich gemacht und hat dann äh ja alle möglichen russischen Behörden irgendwie Staatsanwaltschaft, Ermittlung mit Unterlagen versorgt, was sich da halt tut.
Und äh ja und drei Wochen später wurde ihm Magnitzki verhaftet und äh äh ziemlich
übelst äh gefoltert und ähm verschiedenen Gefängnissen wurde dann krank. Ich meine, der war 36 Jahre alt und wurde dann im Grunde genommen innerhalb von wenigen Monaten zu Tode gefoltert.
Dort äh weil äh und zwar mit äh dem dem dem Ziel, dass er seine Aussagen
zurückzieht äh mit den 250 Millionen, dass das irgendwie illegal war und er hat es aber nicht getan und äh ja, ist dann in Russland äh zu Tode gefoltert worden und
als Ergebnis gab's dann in den USA eben eine Gesetzgebung, den speziellen Akt, den es auch in ganz, ganz vielen anderen äh Ländern gibt. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Deutschland
auch äh so etwas hat
äh mittlerweile, aber äh wenn nicht äh fände ich das halt äh ja sehr sehr äh feige, weil äh ja dieser Magnickske Act
hat dann im Prinzip alle die irgendwie darin verwickelt waren ungefähr zehn, 20 Leute oder so äh
unter ähm ewige Sanktionen und äh Ausreiseverbot und äh oder Einreiseverbote und
andere Dinge äh gestellt so. Das fand ich dann schon bemerkens äh wert äh wie ja äh.
Äh genau Browder äh.
Ja, also da hat äh dieser William äh äh Browder äh doch äh irgendwie äh ziemlich krassen Einfluss äh ausgibt und dann sagen.
Ähm und ja man kann sagen ähm okay, das ist jetzt so ein amerikanischer Milliardär, der dann äh irgendwo dann äh amerikanische Gesetzgebung beeinflusst hat äh um
für einen einen Freund dann für Gerechtigkeit äh zu sorgen, aber äh das fand ich dann mal durchaus einen äh eine eine
Aktion, wo äh wo ich sagen kann, okay äh gut gemacht. Und äh.
Eigentlich, wie gesagt, das ist das ist so ein übler Haufen äh Nord.
Kurzer Hintergrund ähm Deutschland, es gab eine Petition in diesem Magnitzkieck auch in Deutschland durch zu äh setzen nach 80.000 Unterschriften bekommen. Das war so das nötige Quorum. Wurde dann auch äh kam auch zu einer öffentlichen Anhörung im Petitionsausschuss.
Juni 20 20 haben sich da verschiedene Bundestagsabgeordnete für äh ausgesprochen.
Sowohl von der CDU, SPD als auch FDP als auch Grüne.
Und äh Merkel und Maas aufgefordert dann doch mal sowas auf EU-Ebene, mal auch durchzusetzen. Das ist glaube ich so ein bisschen der letzte äh Stand.
Äh einer derjenigen, die das vorangetrieben haben, ist manuell Sarrazin von den Grünen. Ich weiß nicht, ob von dem schon mal gehört hast, aber der wurde gerade vor kurzem von äh
Frau Bärbock, unserer neuen Außenministerin für äh als die ähm als Sonderbeauftragter für den äh Balkan.
Berufen für den Westbalkan und ähm hat also durchaus Einfluss. Mit anderen Worten da ist noch nix passiert, aber es könnte durchaus sein.
Da äh noch was kommt.
Ja, das wäre ja mal, wäre mal äh dann vielleicht auch gerade ein ein guter
Anlass äh oder so, dass vielleicht auch nochmal jetzt jetzt auf äh zugreifen und äh ja äh einfach äh diese,
diese Mörder
so anders kann man kann man die nicht nennen Diebe, Räuber und und Mörder ähm äh dort dort dort wirklich äh zur Rechenschaft äh zu ziehen und.
Ja und in ich meine insgesamt ja auch schon gesagt, ich war ja auch eher immer so ein bisschen so ein,
Putin-Versteher, wobei äh Sankt Putin zu verstehen, jetzt nicht unbedingt
heißen äh muss, dass man das irgendwo akzeptiert, äh was er macht, sondern ich wenn das eher äh äh äh wichtig. Aber ich würde mich sogar so ein bisschen als Putin-Apologeten äh äh bezeichnen, also dass ich eben
ja durchaus auch Verständnis für seine Situation gehabt,
habe und in einer schweren oder komplizierten Umgebung äh muss man eben auch schwierige, komplizierte.
Entscheidungen treffen aber äh wenn man sich äh tatsächlich auch Putins äh komplette Karriere anguckt.
Die begonnen damit, dass er ja äh ja von äh der Hungernden.
Bevölkerung äh des des Geld gestohlen hat, was eigentlich für äh Nahrungsmittelbeschaffung ähm dienen äh sollte und hat sich dann äh von da aus äh ich sage mal hoch,
äh und hochentwickelt, um ja mit den fiesesten Giften, äh die es so so gibt,
äh zu morden und zu töten und äh zu foltern und nach außen aber irgendwie immer den äh ja Saubermann äh zu geben beziehungsweise immer erfolgreich so eine so schön Haus.
Die äh die äh zu sorgen, aber eigentlich ganz äh trotzdem halt Messages äh zu senden. Und.
Ansonsten äh ja, ich kenne halt auch äh.
Leute persönlich, die äh dort.
Auch mal ja deren deren deren Familie äh dort auch äh hohe Posten im Kreml äh bekleidet hat und.
Die ähm sind,
grade äh ja die haben Angst. Also die haben richtig Angst so, weil äh dort so Dinge äh passieren wohl, die von denen die Medien überhaupt.
Nichts mitbekommen oder keine Ahnung haben, aber so ein Ding ist.
Gibt auf der einen Seite diese ganzen Giftmorde, wo wo Putin halt eine Message äh gesendet hat. Aber wenn es darum geht, jetzt einfach
Leute aus dem Weg äh zu schaffen intern äh was halt nicht so international Schlagzeilen machen muss ist halt der Herzinfarkt,
das Mittel der Wahl. So und dann sterben einfach plötzlich ganz ganz viele Leute an Herzinfarkt und ähm ich habe
versucht rauszufinden, ob jetzt grade auch vielleicht in Kreml äh gerade äh wieder irgendwo äh die Prävalenz an Herzinfarkten, die in Russland sowieso achtmal so hoch ist, wie im Westen, aber das wird wahrscheinlich andere Gründe.
Ähm aber ob es da jetzt grade vielleicht auch wieder zu einer Häufung von Herzinfarkten kommt, wie glaube ich zuletzt
ich 2tausend17 oder so äh sind dann plötzlich auf der ganzen Welt ähm glaube in den in,
zehn Monaten sind so acht Diplomaten äh an ganz merkwürdigen Herzinfarkten.
Verstorben und ja das war wohl so eine von Putin durchgeführte Säuberungsaktion im diplomatischen Dienst.
So wurde der mal eben alles an Diplomaten äh ausgeschaltet hat. Äh,
was äh ja irgendwie nicht so aufs auf seiner Linie waren und seitdem ist halt auch der gesamte diplomatische Dienst äh so die äh ja
die leben halt in Angst und und Schrecken seitdem und da traut sich halt auch keiner mehr so richtig die Klappe aufzumachen. Mittlerweile.
Und.
Ja, ich meine Frage ist, was machen wir jetzt? Äh ich meine, wie wie treten wir irgendwie so einem Mafia-Boss äh im im Grunde genommen,
ja gegen gegenüber der der eigentlich nur ja den Politiker spielt.
Na, ich denke, jetzt ist es erst mal Prioritäten setzen angesagt und die erste Priorität ist, äh die Ukraine so weit zu unterstützen, dass sie sich ähm
das Drama, was ich jetzt schon abgezeichnet habe, zumindest in irgendwelchen Grenzen halten kann. Noch ist da auch viel zu retten,
und ich habe so den Eindruck, das wird aber auch getan.
Parallel dazu müssen wir uns halt ähm jetzt auch am Riemen reißen.
Und äh insbesondere was halt die Energiesituation betrifft hier endlich mal Maßnahmen ergreifen, die jetzt auch wirklich eine Änderung.
Bringen. Auch das muss ich sagen, sehe ich derzeit ähm was heißt auf einem guten Weg, aber.
Wir haben zumindest jetzt eine Regierung.
Gerade gewählt zufällig die so im Kern dieses richtige Mindset mitbringt dafür.
Und wer noch so ein bisschen Überzeugungsarbeit gebraucht hat innerhalb äh dieses Regierungsplans, denke ich mal, dürfte die jetzt auch gefunden haben. Ist jetzt einfach klar, dass wir irgendwie.
Dafür sorgen müssen, dass nicht länger mit.
Gasheizung und Ölheizung geheizt wird. So und selbstverständlich brauchen wir halt ein Verbot von Gas- und Ölheizung nicht von Bestand, sondern eben von neuen.
Es darf einfach kein Haus mehr gebaut werden, wo mit Gas geheizt wird, Punkt.
Ganz einfach. Andere Länder haben das schon gemacht. Warum gibt's sowas in Deutschland äh nicht? Selbstverständlich muss es eine Pflicht geben äh bei Neubauten.
Und bei Gewerbe äh Bauten irgendwie Solaraus bauen. Selbstverständlich brauchen wir bessere äh und kürzere Wege
den Windausbau voranzutreiben und solche Blockadehaltungen wie Bayern das jetzt über Jahre gezeigt hat, gehen halt einfach überhaupt nicht mehr. Selbstverständlich müssen wir jetzt auch irgendwie kurzfristig.
Schlimme Entscheidungen fällen. Ja, also so was wie.
Hm das jetzt die Braunkohle unser letzter äh unser Lars Resort ist, wenn es irgendwie darum geht äh Netzbedarf auszugleichen, das ist bitter
so, ja, aber es ist halt einfach eine eine Konsequenz der Politik, die wir gefahren haben. Aber das Hauptproblem ist halt wirklich, dass äh
Heizen und äh auch da muss eben europäisch vorangegangen werden. Also es muss also europäische
Stromnetze, europäische äh Gasnetze aufgebaut werden, alle alle Möglichkeiten müssen halt herangezogen werden, aber es darf halt jetzt einfach nicht weiter gebremst werden, weil diese Abhängigkeit von Russland, die muss halt weg und das ist eben das, was jetzt langfristig auch
wirklich schaden wird. Inwiefern sich das Problem Putin jetzt kurzfristig lösen wird.
Das können wir alle nicht so richtig beurteilen. Das wird jetzt auch extrem vom Verlauf dieses Krieges abhängen. Umso.
Schlimmer das jetzt für die Russen kommt, umso schneller das geht oder umso dramatischer diese Niederlage am Ende äh ausfallen wird.
Umso größer sind die Chancen, dass man einen Putin loswird, nur wenn du einen Putin los wirst, dann wird der ja nicht gleich durch durch Gorbatschow ersetzt.
Genau, genau. Äh ja, ich ich denke.
Aus dem auch aus dem, was was wir vorhin gesagt haben, ergibt sich ja, okay, Putin kriegen wir weg, indem wir eben schwach aussehen lassen.
Ähm,
und ich sage mal mit kriegen wir weg, äh meine ich jetzt, er hätte es eigentlich verdient nach all dem. Also es wäre halt mehr so eine äh so ein Akt der Gerechtigkeit, ja, wenn es ihm wirklich äh ja äh.
Putin Ac.
Wenn wenn wenn er äh äh wenn er wirklich ein ein ein schlimmes äh Schicksal erleidet so, aber das ist das ist eher so ein so ein persönliches Ding, aber
der würde dann halt einfach nur durch.
Eine neue Person durch irgendeinen der Prinzen äh dann ersetzt werden, äh der vielleicht sogar noch noch noch schlimmer äh äh wäre möglicherweise. Es ist mir halt so durch den Kopf geht eigentlich,
müsste man ja irgendwie versuchen,
auch äh ja äh Russland ähm also einen einen Kulturwandel tatsächlich äh in in Russland hinzubekommen, dass die halt,
endlich mal aufhören äh nach ich sage mal 5hundert Jahre.
Äh mongolischen äh Prinzipien äh äh dort dort zu leben und vielleicht äh mal einen einen einen Staat und eine Organisation äh hinbekommen, die die nicht auf,
dieser ja die eben nicht auf äh Diebstahl und äh Gewalt und.
Äh Mord äh und Korruption basiert so und auf Lügen. Aber
Das ist natürlich etwas äh ja äh es ist ja natürlich die Frage, steht uns das überhaupt zu, so von von außen jetzt irgendwie äh zu wollen oder zu verlangen oder zu versuchen
jetzt Russlands Kultur äh zu ändern, aber auf.
Wollen dürfen wir.
Nur machen.
Ja äh nur ich ich
ich denke auch auch gerade äh so ähm also dieses dieses Land mit oder ohne äh Putin äh habe ich das Gefühl, stellt einfach mal eine massive Gefahr auch
für die äh Sicherheit
der Welt äh da und ähm ja eine eine direkte Lösung habe ich da jetzt jetzt auch nicht, aber zumindest ist mir jetzt erstmal klar geworden, eigentlich
ja braucht braucht es mehr als einfach nur einen.
Regierungs äh wechsel oder auch nur einen einen Regime äh Wechsel, das das finde ich jetzt, sondern also eigentlich okay.
Eigentlich meiner Meinung nach, was sie äh Russen bräuchten, was glaube ich funktionieren würde, äh wäre sagen sie eine Art Diktator, also jemanden, der halt auf der einen Seite
äh auch wirklich den den den starken Mann äh zeigen
kann und und und spielen kann, aber äh tatsächlich dann ein Ziel verfolgt, wirklich die russische Gesellschaft äh zu modernisieren und äh aus dem 15. Jahrhundert äh in
die Gegenwart zu holen oder ein Stück weit in die Gegenwart zu bewegen und ich glaube schon hm dass das theoretisch zumindest,
gehen, gehen äh kann, aber äh nicht, indem man äh dort einfach die Demokratie
einführt, das glaube ich würde nur dazu führen, dann äh äh wieder sagen wir mal Wiederholung von von von Yal ziehen, sondern die brauchen einen starken Mann äh so, aber einen, der
der dann äh ja,
nicht so mörderisch äh ist, aber der sich, der muss sich dann natürlich auch behaupten irgendwie in diesen in in auch einem äh Situation. Also der sagen wir mal so, der müsste wahrscheinlich auch Köpfe rollen lassen.
So erstmal in größerer Zahl.
Das wäre auch nochmal eine Option.
Ah das wäre ja das das wäre natürlich ich meine das wäre natürlich auch für also für Russland wäre das natürlich auch interessant, weil dort ja eigentlich das die Frauen äh sind äh die,
eigentlich theoretisch äh das Sagen haben, zumindest in der in der Familie. Es berichtet mir halt auch mein Freund, der äh äh eine äh russische Ehefrau äh äh hat und äh ja.
Und insofern äh ja das wäre vielleicht überhaupt die Lösung. Äh also.
Super, da bin ich ja froh, dass wir jetzt nach äh über zwei Stunden endlich die Lösung gefunden haben, um die ganzen.
Aufzulösen. Das war ja eigentlich auch mein Ziel. Warum dann auch keiner vorher drauf gekommen ist.
Genau. Russland braucht einfach eine eine äh eine eine starkes, skrupellose Frau äh so an der an der Spitze äh die irgendwie äh ja.
Gut, dann lass uns jetzt hier äh beenden unsere Analyse. Ich hoffe, das äh hat euch allen in irgendeiner Form wieder mal Erkenntnisse gebracht.
Ähm das meiste von dem, was wir jetzt hier angesprochen haben, findet sich in irgendwelchen Berichten wieder, die wir auch verlinkt haben.
Sicherlich nicht vollständig, weil die Wahrnehmung, die wir jetzt haben und das, was wir auch selber aus der Situation heraus lernen.
Ist ja auch manchmal so eine ein Gesamteindruck aus all den News-Items und sonstigen Hintergrund äh Sachen, die man so liest. Äh da kann man jetzt nicht unbedingt immer wieder sagen, ja hier in diesem Artikel steht das und in diesem Artikel steht das. Also äh
nur.
Steht uns nicht falsch. Wir arbeiten hier jetzt nicht mit so einer komplett durchbelegten Liste äh von Wahrheiten, sondern wir sammeln unsere Eindrücke, aber wir haben halt auch immer wieder so einzelne
Berichte und Kommentare zur Situation, auf die wir speziell verweisen, die insideful sind. Und ja, die findet ihr auch in den Shownotes.
Ja ja und wir versuchen natürlich auch nicht zu sehr na jetzt irgendwie in in Begeisterung äh zu zu verfallen äh oder oder nur nur die Dinge.
Ähm anzunehmen, die,
von denen wir gerne hätten, dass sie wahr äh sind äh ähm ja,
aber ja ich denke äh noch ist also der Krieg ist noch nicht verloren.
So und er ist aber auch noch nicht gewonnen äh so. Also es ist es ist die Situation ist.
Offen und kann äh tatsächlich in die eine oder andere äh Richtung äh gehen, was jetzt die militärische Situation äh angeht. Politisch zeichnet sich äh mittlerweile ab,
äh ja ähm wird,
so nicht zu gewinnen sein oder es ist irgendwie schon verloren und alleine nur mit dem, was bisher passiert ist, ähm an an an Schäden, an Vertrauensschäden,
auf der einen Seite was Russland angeht an Kapital was abgezogen wird,
und nie wiederkommen wird an Firmen, die jetzt in Russland,
zusammenbrechen werden oder zum Teil zusammen gebrochen sind, die nicht mehr werden äh wiederbelebt äh werden können.
Viele Rossen äh qualifizierte und junge Russen eigentlich der der produktivsten Generation, die gerade das Land verlassen. Viele von denen werden
auch nicht äh wieder zurückkommen und die jetzt Einigkeit der NATO und die aufgestockten.
Rüstungshaushalte und so, das wird jetzt auch erstmal äh äh eine ganze Weile äh bleiben und ich glaube mit diesem,
Angriff jetzt schon hat äh Russland einfach sehr sehr viel äh was,
Putin in den letzten 20 Jahren so nach und nach an klugen Dingen und hinterhältigen Dingen äh so an Einfluss im im Westen und
an äh ja Zwietracht im Westen äh gesät hat so. Das hat er jetzt alles schon mal verloren. Das ist das ist schon mal weg und äh jetzt bleibt halt nur noch na ja ähm.
Wie sieht's da militärisch äh aus und äh wie wie und,
Bei Putin geht's jetzt um um seinen Kopf. Äh wenn äh und ähm deswegen fürchte ich mhm
könnte sich äh diese dieser ganze Krieg auch auch hinziehen. Ich meine, Afghanistan ging zehn Jahre für die Russen und 20 Jahre für uns. Ich meine, ich hoffe nicht, dass da jetzt die nächsten zehn oder 20 Jahre Ukrainekrieg
haben dann Podcast glaube ich auch.
No way, Mister Putin. Auf keinen Fall.
Ja, genau, genau. Also dann dann ja dann müsste da wirklich was was was unternehmen.
Wir müssen uns noch in dieser Dekade noch über über über interessante Sachen unterhalten. Also über interessantere Sachen unterhalten. Okay, ich mache jetzt hier Klappe äh zu für heute. Äh tschüss, bis bald ähm.
Fleißig und wir hören uns dann die nächsten Tage wieder. Bis dann, tschüss.
Bis denn.